Okay, Leute, auf geht's, kurz mal schauen, wird das Licht ein bisschen weiter hochdrehen hier, äh, wo habe ich es denn hier, Licht, was, hä, ach, ne, ist noch gar nicht volle Pulle, jetzt ist es 100%, gut, jetzt ist es auch ein bisschen heller hier drin, weil ich brauche jetzt ja gleich wieder die Kamera, dass das funktioniert.
Gut, lasst mal kurz, lasst mal kurz, bevor es, bevor alle da sind, bevor es richtig losgeht, lasst mal kurz Probe machen, ob alles funktioniert, ja, schön, dass ihr alle jetzt schon da seid, fühlt sich fast wie Abo-Box-Gecamper an, so schnell wir hier am Start sind, lasst mal, lasst mal kurz was ausprobieren, also, jetzt, äh, ich muss das Ding mal sinnvoll benennen, das, genau, so, jetzt müsstet ihr die Kamera sehen, hallo, hallo, Leute, so, Kamera, Pongos,
Rename, okay, und jetzt müsstet ihr das Elgato-Zeug sehen, wo noch nichts dran ist, aber, müsstet, müsstet gehen, ja, ne, ja, ich sehe es in der Vorschau, hat alles funktioniert, ja, nice, okay, gut, muss ja, muss ja gleich funktionieren, sonst seht ihr nichts.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, very Pogu, nice, okay, da können wir anfangen.
Leute, oh, hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Twitch-Benachrichtigung hyperfast, ja, die sind deutlich schneller als der Bot, der Bot, der Bot, der ist, hey, teilweise ein ziemlicher Aussetzer, ich glaube, da müssen wir uns auch mal irgendeinen anderen Bot raussuchen, ich weiß nicht, warum der nicht richtig funktioniert, der Bot ist wirklich Keckel, Alter.
Der Bot ist eigentlich permanent hier so unterwegs, was, teilweise halbe Stunde später.
Ich werde ich dieses, äh, den Stream heute auch als Hintergrund benutzen, paar Ausschnitte aus dem Stream im Hintergrund benutzen, wenn ich, sollte ich dazu ein YouTube-Video machen, so, zumindest mal ein paar Sachen, weil da muss ich die Hardware, muss ich nicht zweimal aufschrauben und sowas, wenn wir uns das jetzt zusammen angucken, ja, ob ich den, ob ich den Chat jetzt reinmache, eher nicht.
Leute, bis, solange der Stream startet, solange der Stream startet, soll ich euch mal die, die fertig eingerichtete Linux-Kiste zeigen?
Das, wo wir die letzten paar Streams dran rumgebaut haben
Ich hab auf Stream noch ein bisschen weiter gemacht
Was heißt fertig? Fertig ist das Ganze natürlich nie
Fertig ist das Ganze natürlich
Das ist ja, also fertig werden solche Dinger nicht
Ich zeige euch jetzt aber was richtig cooles
Guck mal, ich hab jetzt Chat-GPT
Chat-GPT bei mir auf der Kommandozeile
So, und den können wir zum Beispiel
Chat-GPT können wir irgendwas fragen von der Shell aus
Zum Beispiel das hier, was ich vorhin schon mal ausprobiert hab
Hier, explain this command rsync-va info progress
Also, ich weiß was das Kommando macht
rsync-v ist mehr Detailinfos
a ist Archivmodus, da bleiben Permissions und sowas gleich
Und progress ist, dass man angezeigt bekommt
Bei welchem Status er gerade ist
Transfer
Jetzt gucken wir mal was Chat-GPT dazu
Sagt
Der braucht ein bisschen Chat-GPT, ist ja nicht das Allerschnellste
Aber meistens tauchen dafür die Antworten
Man kann es leider nicht genau einschätzen
Ob es taugt
Postchamp
Dead
Wrong
Nochmal abbrechen
Fragen wir mal was anderes
Explain Kekkel
Okay, der hat keinen Bock
Der will nicht
Chat-GPT denkt sich nope
Es kann auch sein, dass Chat-GPT gerade überlastet ist
Das passiert ja Chat-Opener, das passiert ja immer wieder
Normalerweise würde es dann
Ich überleg gerade
Hat das mein Login irgendwie vergessen oder so?
Was auch immer, muss ich mal anprobieren
Ich hab noch was anderes
Ich hab zweimal Chat-GPT Hilftools am Start
Einmal kann man direkt Chat-GPT fragen
Also, wahrscheinlich ich hab vorhin
Ach, jetzt geht's!
Chat-GPT Session is not usable
Okay, ich hab meine Session vorhin gelöscht
Deswegen geht das nicht
Deswegen funktioniert das
Okay, das leuchtet natürlich ein
So, und ich hab noch was anderes mit der Chat-GPT API
Die kannst du zum Beispiel fragen
Ähm
How to sync, keine Ahnung
Tool
Two directories
Ähm
On Linux
Das geht jetzt über die API
Und kostet Geld
Das da oben emuliert Chat-GPT mit einer Browser-Session
Und kostet kein Geld
Geht natürlich auch viel schneller
Und ist, das ist quasi die AI, die dahinter steckt von GitHub
Copilot
Und das hier oben ist halt direkt so ein
So ein CLI-Tool für Chat-GPT
Das unten geht auch viel schneller
Guck, kann sagen
Ask how to sync
Und das ist gar nicht schlecht
Das ist relativ gut
Ja, leider kann man jetzt
Copilot hat keine Sessions, wo ich ihn fragen kann
Hier, explain this command
Das könnte ich dann
Das könnte ich dann mit Chat-GPT machen
Chat-GPT kann ich fragen
Hier, explain
Explain
Explain this command
Funktioniert aber nicht, weil meine Session irgendwie kaputt ist
Zumindest habe ich mir gedacht
Ohne AI auf der Kommando-Zeile geht da gar nichts mehr heutzutage
Muss ja, muss ja sein
Also das hier ist tendenziell für Kommandos
Kannst du der AI dann auch Aufgaben geben?
Ne, ich kann die, ich kann die fragen
Ich kann die fragen
Die Chat-GPT-Antworten sind potenziell besser
Als die von Commandos
Als die von CodePilot
Also das hier ist CodePilot
Das ist Chat-GPT
Die, die Antworten von, von CodePilot sind oftmals schneller und präzise auf den Punkt
Chat-GPT sind aber umfangreicher und eigentlich besser
Leider, leider bin ich grad nicht, nicht, nicht eingeloggt
Ich könnte mich kurz einloggen bei Chat-GPT
Da muss ich euch aber mal
Okay
Ich switch euch einfach mal kurz um auf die Kamera
Hallo Chat
Ihr dürft jetzt, ihr dürft jetzt grad nicht nachgucken
Chat-GPT login
So, ich log mich bei Chat-GPT
Mal kurz ein
Oh, ich glaube jetzt hat's funktioniert
Okay, okay, erst jetzt hat's funktioniert
Ich schalte euch wieder um
Okay, jetzt, jetzt hat's funktioniert
So, jetzt kann ich nämlich sagen
Chat, Chat-GPT
Explain, explain, explain, lol, weh
Beste Frage
Gucken, ob das, ob's das weiß
Lol, it's a commonly used emote in online communication
Man kann, man kann übrigens auch an der Stelle
Kann man übrigens auch sagen hier
Answer in German
Man kann auch, man kann auch Gleichfrage
Erkläre die Herkunft von lol, weh
Nicht, dass man das jetzt irgendwie brauchen würde
Alles fit, jo, wir bauen heute Emulator-Kiste
Lol, weh ist eine Abkürzung, die in der Online-Gaming-Community
Und im Streamingfeld steht für
Wisst ihr, jetzt, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Aber was viel, was viel interessanter ist
Man kann zum Beispiel hier fragen
Man kann Code-Pilot fragen
Man kann das verbinden
How to sync to directories
Ah, siehste
Das würde ich jetzt so ohne weiteres nicht machen
Delete sorgt nämlich dafür
Dass im Destination-Directory Sachen gelöscht werden
Die es im Source nicht mehr gibt
Aber jetzt könnte ich sagen
Chat-GPT
Äh, erklär mir mal das hier, please
Guck
Und
Erklärt, jetzt erklärt ihr mir sogar die einzelnen Parameter
Was die machen
A ist Archive-Mode
V ist Verbose-Mode
Eigentlich ziemlich cool, oder?
Es ist fast schneller wie Explain-Shell
Und man kann, man kann, man kann Chat-Chat
Man kann übrigens Chat-GPT auch auf Deutsch fragen
So, keine Ahnung
Wie
Lass mal ein bisschen was, lass mal ein bisschen was
Was komplizierteres machen
Äh, wie aktiviere ich
SSH-Multiplexing in der Config
Ey, wenn's das weiß, ist Sixhead
Vor allem auf Deutsch
Okay
Nett schlecht, nett schlecht
Das trifft, das stimmt, das stimmt
Gut, das da hinten kann man nennen, wie man will
Aber das ist eigentlich schon relativ gut, ja
Also für solche Sachen, für solche Sachen ist das aber wirklich nice
Chat-GPT labert immer unglaublich viel, ja
Das hört, das hört immer überhaupt nicht auf
Das reicht eigentlich schon
Das ist alles, was ich bräuchte
Aber Chat-GPT schreibt immer einen halben Rum
Schreibt immer einen halben Roman dazu
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla
Ich meine, ich könnte einfach abbrechen
Ja, eigentlich ganz, ganz nice
Jo
Und was habe ich die Woche so verpasst?
Gab's irgendwas spannendes?
Bisschen, bisschen laut
Wie, wie es C++ findet
Okay, okay
Wie findest du C++?
Das kann sein, dass ich das quoten muss
Ich kann mir schon denken, was die sagen
Genau
Genau, die sagt wieder ihr übliches Ding.
Die sagt wieder ihr übliches Ding.
Das, das, das, oder, oder, das antwortet immer so.
So nach dem Motto, ich kann dazu persönlich sagen.
C++ ist eine sehr mächtige und viels...
Okay, wir müssen, wir müssen anders fragen.
Wir müssen anders fragen.
Warum ist C++ so kacke?
Ach ja, ach ja.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Es ist wichtig zu beachten, dass die Meinungen über...
Was über eine Programmiersprache subjektiv sind und von der Erfahrung und der Anforderung des Einzelnen abhängt.
Das, das macht das Ding immer.
Das macht das Ding immer so super, ähm...
Ja, wie soll ich sagen, so ausgeglichen, ja?
Okay, probieren wir mal.
Wir machen das mal auf Deutsch.
Generiere eine Liste, wo Contra...
C++.
Oh.
Ich hab mich verschrieben.
Mal gucken, ob es das checkt.
Oh.
Okay, nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Antworte in...
Muss man vielleicht nochmal explizit dazu sagen.
Oh.
Das geht nicht.
Das...
Broken.
Aber jetzt, jetzt.
Ich hab mich, ich hab mich verschrieben.
Ich hab mich verschrieben.
Deswegen hat es nicht auf Deutsch gemacht.
C++ hat eine sehr hohe Leistung und ist daher für Systemprogrammierer und Anwendungen mit hohen Anforderungen an die Rechenleistung...
Okay, das würde ich so nicht sagen.
Das klingt sehr durch die Brust ins Auge formuliert, aber gut.
C++ hat eine steeper Lernkurve als andere Sprachen.
Oh, das stimmt.
Die ist ganz...
Die ist steep...
Die ist deutlich steeper, die Lernkurve, als bei anderen Sprachen.
ChatGPT ist easy installierbar.
Es gibt ein Kommando.
Es gibt jemand, der hat die API nachgebaut und ein Kommandozeilentool dafür.
Oder die API.
Also, die hat die API.
Die hat die API.
Mitgesnipht im Browser und dann das nach...
Kommandozeilentool nachgebaut.
Lukas, Danke schön für den Sub.
Aber eigentlich, Holger, wollte ich heute eine Emulator Kiste bauen.
Okay, fragen wir mal.
Was ist die beste Linux-Distribution für No...
... für Spieleemulation?
Was...
Wenn ich jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte.
One Stripes.
Die API ist public, aber die kostet was.
Es gibt keine einzige beste.
Das ist immer so dieses, die drücken das alles so super diplomatisch immer aus.
Ein Arch Linux mit einem Emulationsstation Frontend.
Okay.
Arch, by the way.
Wir machen das heute auch mit Bartoszera.
Ich habe das übrigens im Titel falsch geschrieben, sehe ich gerade.
Muss ich vielleicht nochmal richtig schreiben.
So.
Alles klar.
Gut, jetzt haben wir, wir haben glaube ich Chat-GPT jetzt genug gequält.
Ja, wir können, wir können, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Okay, wir vergleichen das jetzt mal.
Wir vergleichen mal CodePilot und Chat.
Okay, Chat-GPT.
Copy ISO to USB Stick on Linux.
Dd-Command, das ist schon mal gut.
Dd-if, da, da.
Ja, hey, das ist, das ist gut so.
So kann man das machen.
Okay, als Caliglabo Chat-GPT reicht jetzt.
Das ist genug.
Ich muss, ich muss den Standard-Error-Kram hier irgendwie mal wegmachen.
Jedes Mal, wenn man, wenn man Control-Dings drückt.
Ich, warte mal, lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Wo habe ich denn hier meinen Alias dafür?
Ähm.
Ach so, ich kann sogar translaten in der, in der Shell.
Kann ich euch auch gleich mal zeigen.
Äh, Chat-GPT.
Ah, hier.
Def.
Ach nee, das funktioniert ja an der Stelle nicht.
Ha, Mist.
Weil das ja ein Alias ist.
Da müsste ich eine Function draus machen, dass ich es umleiten kann.
Na, egal.
Okay, also wir haben Chat, wir haben Chat-GPT gerade gefragt.
Sagt, äh, Dd.
So.
How to copy ISO to USB Stick on Linux.
Fast.
Western mit SSH default starten, das ist ganz einfach.
Dd-ISO.
Ja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Mit 4M ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoller, aber okay.
Also man muss, man muss sagen, Copilot ist deutlich auf, deutlich mehr auf den Punkt.
Sagt aber auch öfters, wenn es keine Ahnung hat.
Chat-GPT schwätzt immer drei Stunden rum, äh, was du gar nicht wissen willst.
Okay, was soll ich fragen?
Frag jetzt mal, wie man eine Windows-ISO unter Linux auf einen USB-Stick kopiert.
Okay.
Das ist, das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich, äh, high IQ.
How to, ähm, was soll ich fragen?
How to create bootable Windows, Windows-USB-Stick on Linux.
Und wie?
Das ist einfach.
Du sagst, du sagst, äh, äh, change shell und dann minus S, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, so.
Wir fragen Chat-GPT gerade mal.
Wir fragen Chat-GPT.
Ich glaube, das ist das richtige Kommando.
Dann stell, äh, änderst du deine Default-Shell.
Okay, was, äh, was erzählen sie uns?
There are few ways to create bootable USB-Stick on Linux, but one of the most common is use
DD-Command.
Nein, das funktioniert nicht.
There are the two general steps.
Insert USB, use DD.
Siehste?
Chat-GPT erzählt halt einfach Mist.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Ja, das, das funktioniert eher.
Das funktioniert nicht, was Chat-GPT uns erzählt.
Aber wir können mal, wir, wir fragen mal Ars, äh, Dings, äh, Copilot.
Nein.
Die haben beide keine Ahnung davon.
Okay.
Ähm, aber wir können, wir können sie fragen, how to change your shell from bash.
Mal gucken.
To change, you can use the command.
Leko, so funktioniert das.
Guck, guck.
So funktioniert das.
Und dann musst du dich neu einloggen und dann funktioniert das.
Okay, Chat-gpt fehlt dir nicht die Klappe.
Also, dass muss man sagen, Chat-GPT-Antworten sind immer extrem ausschweifend.
Guck, Copilot ist auf dem Punkt.
Look at me, bam, so funktioniert's.
Und übrigens, das ist korrekt.
So würde ich's machen.
So würde ich's nicht.
Also, ich würde es so machen, wie Copilot sagt, und nicht wie, und nicht wie, äh, wie,
und nicht wie Chat-GPT
sagen. Muss ich sagen, unter der Haube
ist da viel Gemeinsames, aber
im Detail unterscheiden sich die Antworten
doch manchmal. Genau, Chat-GPT
macht immer so auf schlau.
Ich kann übrigens auch direkt auf das
DLi translaten mittlerweile.
Volle AI-Power.
Wir können zum Beispiel
übersetzen,
warum ist der Twitch-Chat
heute so...
Das wird er nicht checken, aber okay.
Wow.
Was geht?
Okay, das...
Okay, manchmal kackt es ein bisschen.
Warum ist der Twitch-Chat
heute so cute? Warum ist er...
Okay.
Why is the Twitch-Chat
so smart today? Okay, das passt.
Was geht? What works?
Naja gut, der hat halt überhaupt kein...
Der hat halt überhaupt keinen Kontext.
Was geht ist eher so eine Frage, was ist los?
What's up? Aber
das weiß der ja aus dem Kontext nicht.
Also man muss das, was man sieht,
man muss das...
Man muss das alles immer doppelt und dreifach
sich nochmal angucken, ob das auch alles so passt.
Der Rest ist doch durchaus in Ordnung.
Kann man sich doch nicht beschweren.
So.
Aber genug AI-Shit.
Guck mal, wie schön der
Pepo durchschimmert hier im Hintergrund.
Seht ihr den?
White Pepo Happy.
Gibt's sonst noch Linux-technisch was,
was ich euch zeigen kann?
Ähm...
Ich hab meinen Rofi gethemed.
Und?
Guck, hier sieht er jetzt so aus.
Ja, ich kann jetzt...
Ich kann jetzt Programme starten,
grafische Anwendungen starten, Windows switchen,
Emojis einfügen.
Ich hab meinen Clipboard-Manager.
Ich kann ein paar spezielle Skripts starten,
die ich mir reingehauen...
Zum Beispiel kann ich mein Clipboard,
mein Clipboard an- und ausschalten,
was man dann da oben auch in der...
In der Leiste sieht, wenn ich beispielsweise mal
ein Passwort in Zwischenablage machen will.
Und man kann...
Und man kann hier übrigens auch drinnen rechnen jetzt.
Weiß ich nicht, wie oft ich das verwenden werde.
Aber man weiß ja nie.
Mal gucken.
Alles fertig gethemed.
Hast du nix?
So, erst schon mal ausbilden.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Okay.
Bar, Tor, Serra, Linux, Download.
Ach so, wir laden uns das mal kurz runter.
Und dann müssen wir ja noch mal auf die Kamera switchen.
Wir müssen uns die Kiste angucken.
Direct Link.
Okay, während das runter lädt,
switche ich schon mal rüber.
So.
Und, so.
Wir gucken uns das an.
Hast du dir das G-Bait-Video von Linus Tech Tips noch angeschaut?
Nee.
Ich glaube, ich wurde aber schon gespoilert, um was es geht.
Nämlich, dass der wohl erzählt,
Powertools sind ganz nice und sowas.
Also eigentlich richtig, richtig, richtig harter G-Bait wieder.
Wie kann man Ensypil lernen,
ohne sich eine Kiste in der Cloud zu mieten?
Geht das auch mit VMware?
Du brauchst weder VMware noch was.
Du kannst einen Container starten,
du kannst, also aber dann keinen Docker-Container,
sondern irgendwie eher so einen LXT-Container,
wo du alles, alles Mögliche machen kannst.
Du kannst eine VM installieren.
Du kannst eine VM installieren, bietet sich sogar an.
Installiere eine VM und mach einen Snapshot,
dass du immer wieder zurück kannst zum Ausprobieren.
Du kannst Ensypil überall laufen lassen.
Du kannst Ensypil auch auf deiner lokalen Kiste laufen lassen
und Sachen ausprobieren.
Das ist unabhängig, das ist unabhängig davon,
ob das, also du, normal, in der Regel führt man Ensypil über SSH aus,
aber das musst du.
Du kannst auch, kannst du auch lokal machen.
Also du kannst auch lokal über SSH machen, so meine ich das.
VMware Free hat keine Snapshots.
Dann musst du BTFS verwenden und selbst Snapshots machen.
Oder was auch immer.
Und du löscht die eine Datei wieder.
Gibt's, du kannst es aber auch im Container machen.
Gibt's, gibt's jede Menge Möglichkeiten.
Was ist die einfachste Methode?
Also ich, ich persönlich würde sagen, die einfachste Methode,
wenn man es schon, wenn man es drauf hat, ist,
irgendein LXC-Container, falls du es, falls du es schon drauf hast.
Du kannst, du kannst es auch in einem Docker-Container machen.
Geht auch.
Kannst auch in Docker.
Wahrscheinlich ist ein Docker-Container am einfachsten.
Docker haben die meisten Leute installiert.
Neuer Job geht erst ab 1.4. los.
Du kannst auch ein Docker-Container starten,
dich mit Shell reinkonnekten und dort dann Ensypil ausführen.
Oder dich per SSH auf ein,
wobei SSH auf ein Docker-Container ist ein bisschen schwierig,
da musst du SSH starten.
Geht auch.
Wahrscheinlich ist es, wahrscheinlich ist es ein Container am einfachsten.
Oder du machst dir nur vor M.
Beides, beides richtig.
Du kannst aber auch lokal auf deiner Kiste testen.
Ist dein neuer PC schneller als ein Apple M2 Pro?
Ich denke, das hängt entscheidend vom Anwendungsbereich ab.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich super optimierte Sachen,
die auf dem, auf der Apple-Kiste schneller sind.
Aber das meiste 0815-Zeug dürfte auf meinem schneller sein.
Also wenn du da jetzt zum Beispiel irgendein neues Spiel spielen willst,
dann ist das bei mir, voraussetzt es würde überhaupt laufen dort,
bestimmt schneller.
Ja.
Kommt drauf an.
Das war fast, das war so eine richtige,
das war so eine richtige Chat-GPT-Antwort, oder?
Es ist, es ist wichtig zu beachten,
dass es mehrere Möglichkeiten gibt,
was man unter am schnellsten bei einem PC verstehen kann.
In der Regel ist das so,
dass mit schneller die, die, die,
so irgendwas, Chat, es gibt so,
Chat-GPT hat so eine ganz spezielle Art und Weise,
wie es antwortet.
Was hast du zuletzt mit deinem 3D-Drucker gedruckt?
Ähm.
Gute Frage, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Wenn es mir jetzt nicht einfällt, wahrscheinlich ein Case.
Ach nee.
Ich habe noch eine zweite Variante hiervon gedruckt.
Guck mal.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das ist?
Das ist eine Lampe.
Guck.
Eine Lampe, da ist ein LED-Panel drinne und ein Micro-Controller.
Ich habe jetzt leider kein Netzteil, um das anzuschließen,
sonst könnte ich es euch zeigen.
Und ich bin mir auch unschlüssig,
ob ich da einen Spannungswandler davor habe oder nicht.
Also vielleicht bräuchte ich da jetzt ein 5-Volt-Netzteil.
Wobei, ich versuche es euch mal zu zeigen.
Ich glaube, ihr guckt ein 5-Volt-Netzteil raus gerade.
Das reicht aber nicht.
Das ist zu kurz.
Wartet mal, lasst mich mal kurz um die Ecke gucken.
Nee, das reicht nicht.
Das reicht nicht.
Ansonsten hätte ich hier höchstens noch ein,
ich weiß nicht, was ich hier machen würde.
Ich hätte hier höchstens noch ein,
ich glaube, ich hätte hier höchstens noch ein,
zwölf-Volt-Netzteil.
Das kann ich da auf keinen Fall anschließen jetzt.
Dann geht es wahrscheinlich kaputt.
Wartet mal, ich habe irgendwo ein zwölf-Volt-Netzteil.
Ich habe jede Menge, ich muss nur finden.
Das müsste eigentlich eins sein.
Hier, lasst mal kurz gucken.
Steht da was drauf?
Fünf Volt, Output, fünf Volt.
Okay, sollte funktionieren.
Fünf Volt, zehn Ampere.
Alter, das ist das fetteste 5-Volt-Netzteil.
Das ist irgendwie nicht das Richtige.
Das ist das Richtige zum reinstecken, oder?
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
irgendwas ist hier ein bisschen verkehrt.
Muss ich erst mal richtig dran machen noch.
Wartet mal.
Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen sidetracked gerade,
aber das, was sein muss, muss sein, ja.
Muss gerade mal kurz hier richtig
Kabel richtig rein machen.
Das ist definitiv ein Stecker,
den man so nicht betreiben sollte,
sage ich euch gleich.
Aber mein 5-Volt stirbt keiner.
So, zack.
So, und jetzt könnte ich da drauf,
jetzt könnte ich aufs Webinterface,
jetzt könnte ich es aufs Webinterface,
und das sieht in der Kamera
mega beschissen aus,
weil du in der Kamera die einzelnen Punkte siehst.
Wenn du das richtig einstellst
und normal drauf guckst,
siehst du die einzelnen Punkte gar nicht so krass.
Jetzt könnte ich ins Webinterface
und da ein bisschen Zeug drin einstellen.
Ja, das habe ich zuletzt gedruckt.
Also eigentlich schon cool,
dass man so Dinger selbst drucken kann.
Sieht auch irgendwie ganz schick aus.
Das ist ein 16x16 LED Matrix, genau.
Spooky Musik.
Gut.
Okay.
Letzte Woche ist dann Toolcheck Plus angekommen.
Nice. Beste.
Habe ich auch im Schrank hängen drüben.
Wie lange hat es gedauert zu drucken?
Oh, das Ding hat ein bisschen gedauert zu drucken.
Das Ding hat ein bisschen gedauert zu drucken.
Ich glaube, das hat bestimmt
fünf Stunden oder so gedruckt.
Schon ein bisschen.
Ich habe die bessere Variante hier.
Einen guten
Swiss Tool.
Swiss Tool Multistells.
Kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Es war relativ lang gedruckt.
Das Ding ist ja auch recht hoch.
16x16. Das könnten
WS2812 LED sein.
Dein Headset rauscht,
wenn du eine VM startest.
Das wundert mich, der Zusammenhang.
Kann das sein,
dass du die Soundkarte in der VM
nicht deaktiviert hast?
Und die komische Dinger macht beim Start?
Mach mal die Soundkarte.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Störung ist.
Mach mal die Soundkarte aus der VM raus.
Und kamen schon
Kollegen zu dir, dass du bitte deine Aufgaben
erklären und übertragen sollst. Ja, klar.
Okay, so.
Jetzt zeige ich euch mal die Kiste, auf der wir heute
was installieren werden.
Und zwar den hier.
Guckt mal.
Und zwar ist das ein
Mini.
Erkennt man was?
Ich muss mal kurz
Fullscreen machen, sonst sehe ich gar nichts.
Kann man
Fullscreen?
Kann man die Vorschau im OBS
irgendwie Fullscreen machen?
Ja, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Brauche ich
Fullscreen.
Sonst sehe ich nämlich nichts.
Gescheit.
So. Also,
hier. Das ist ein
Blubb. Da weiß man, ob man das ordentlich
erkennt. Wahrscheinlich sieht man
das nicht. Mini Forum.
Immer, ey.
Oh, hier. Mini Forum
UM690
Mini PC. 32 GB RAM,
512 GB SSD.
Wir bauen gleich noch eine zweite SSD ein.
Und ein AMD
Ryzen 9 6900
HX. Das bedeutet
auch, da ist eine, wie heißt
das Ding? APU.
Und da ist eine Grafikkarte und alles
mögliche mit drin.
Grafikkarte und CPU.
Also keine dedicated Grafikkarte.
Dafür ist es relativ klein.
So, und als Controller
probieren wir gleich den...
Ich habe noch einen ganz alten
ausgebuddelt hier, Leute. Guckt mal. Das seht ihr auch am
Haupt. Ich habe noch einen alten Xbox
360 Controller ausgebuddelt.
Einen mit Kabel sogar, glücklicherweise.
Und dann können wir
noch einen PS4 Controller ausprobieren.
Und wir können noch einen Wireless.
Weiß nicht, ob die Dinger Bluetooth sind.
Day One 2013
Xbox One Controller.
Leute, das kostet nicht
1000 Euro. Das Ding kostet
zwischen...
zwischen 550
und
850.
Amazon... Ne, Amazon ist
Cheap Bait. Amazon ist richtig dämlich.
Warte mal, ich zeige euch das mal. Ihr müsst...
Also du kannst bei Amazon kaufen.
Da ist es natürlich ein bisschen teurer, aber
du kriegst es billiger. Und zwar
guckt mal.
Amazon
UM690
So, der da.
Dann steht dann da 1000 Euro
und dann müsst ihr hier unten drauf
gehen. Apply 150 Euro
Voucher. Und wenn ihr den Voucher
applied habt, kostet es gleich nur noch 850 Euro.
Warum sie es nicht einfach ohne
Voucher machen und
das auch 850 kosten
lassen, weiß ich nicht. Es ist
total hängen geblieben.
Das ist aber schon die... fast
die Maximalausstattung.
Wenn du ein bisschen warten kannst,
Miniforum Store, wenn du ein bisschen warten
kannst, kriegst du es noch billiger.
Das ist Hardcore Cheap Bait.
UM690
Wenn du ein bisschen
warten kannst, kriegst du es noch billiger.
Solltest du, also guck mal.
Du kriegst es für 560 Euro.
Solltest du tatsächlich...
Ach guck mal.
In Germany gibt es... ach Moment.
Barebone. Okay.
Also sprich, solltest du
warten können.
Noch ein bisschen.
Dann kannst du dir die nackige Variante
kaufen für 560 Euro.
Also wenn du RAM
hast und Zeug hast. Ansonsten
meine Kombination kostet hier... okay.
Ich habe 50 Euro mehr bei Amazon bezahlt.
Dafür, dass ich es direkt habe.
Du kannst natürlich auch so eine Kombination machen.
Wobei ich ehrlich, ganz
im Ernst.
Eventuell würde ich sogar auf Barebone
gehen und mir einen
Low Profile RAM und eine SSD
kaufen.
Wie viel Full? Die Frage verstehe ich
nicht.
Also für 500... also sagen wir mal so.
Das hier ist eigentlich eine gute...
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Kombi.
16 GB RAM reicht für so ziemlich
alles. 512 GB.
Das ist okay.
Es kommen noch Shipping Rates dabei.
Das geht.
Das geht durchaus. Vielleicht kriegt man es auch mal bei irgendeinem
Sale oder so ein bisschen billiger.
Also das passt.
SSD habe ich auch noch rumliegen.
Wir bauen auch gleich noch eine zweite SSD ein.
Wir bauen gleich noch eine zweite
SSD ein. Angeblich kann man da
SSDs einbauen.
So, jetzt habe ich euch das gezahlt.
50 Euro für die Ausstattung, die ich habe.
16 GB ist fast ein bisschen wenig.
Naja.
Ja, es wäre auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, ein bisschen mehr
zu haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Shared Memory ist.
Ehrlich gesagt mit der GPU.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob das Shared Memory ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich mich nicht näher mit beschäftigt
bisher.
Nein, nein, nein. Das ist alles in einem.
850 Euro für
CPU, GPU. Das ist ja so eine Kombi
Kombikiste.
CPU, GPU, SSD und RAM.
Also du kannst das komplett 1 zu 1
betreiben.
Ich habe auch noch SSDs rumliegen.
Da haben sich wie in den letzten Jahren welche angesammelt.
So, also machen wir mal hier den Controller weg.
Gibt es einen Shortcut
OBS in Fullscreen zu machen?
Projektor.
So, also das sind die Controller, die wir ausprobieren.
Dann habe ich hier wieder meinen Trusted
Trusted USB Stick, wo der Kram drauf kommt.
So, und jetzt packen wir das Teil mal schnell aus.
Kurz die
Verpackung weg und dann schauen wir mal rein.
Wie das so aussieht.
Ihr seht, es ist auch original verpackt.
Ich habe noch nichts gemacht.
Einmal den ganzen in den Mülleimer
pfeffern.
So, dann gucken wir mal.
Miniforum.
Ich könnte das Bild drehen.
So, das probieren wir mal.
Wenn ich das Bild drehe.
Das müssen wir mal checken,
ob das funktioniert. Weil dann seht ihr das
in der richtigen, aber dann sieht es halt ein bisschen
schepp aus. Mal ausprobieren kurz.
Wenn ich das Bild drehe. Lass mal kurz hier.
Rotation.
Äh.
Sieht man nichts mehr.
Jetzt ist es aber richtig rum.
Jetzt habe ich es, jetzt habe ich es
richtig, richtig rum
rotated.
Das Problem ist jetzt, jetzt habe ich es,
jetzt habe ich es halt, ähm.
Jetzt stimmt das Seitenverhältnis nicht.
Ja. 16 zu 9.
Ich bräuchte 9 zu 16.
Ne, das funktioniert
so nicht.
Wir müssen uns, wir müssen uns von der Seite angucken.
Sonst müsste ich jetzt, sonst müsste ich jetzt am Handy
rumwursten und so.
Gut, also packen wir das Ding mal aus.
Gucken wir mal rein.
Alles klar.
Ob, obvious.
China,
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Okay, es riecht nach neuer Technik, aber
es stinkt nicht nach billigem China-Kram.
Also es ist nicht so, dass du denkst, du hast jetzt gleich
irgendwelche, ähm,
anderen Verätzungen, wenn du das einatmest.
Also China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Es ist nicht zu, es ist nicht
empfohlen,
für die Customer, den
CPU-Cooler zu entfernen. Ich habe ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht vor, den CPU-Cooler
zu entfernen.
Wenn das Mainboard kaputt geht,
kann man das wegwerfen oder gibt es
einen Ersatz-Mainboard? Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nicht vor, das Mainboard kaputt zu machen.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass es irgendwie so auf einmal
ups, das Mainboard ist kaputt.
Also es ist meistens ja nicht so, dass
das Mainboard einfach so kaputt geht.
Weiß nicht, wie oft euch schon mal das Mainboard kaputt
gegangen ist. Aber wahrscheinlich kannst du es
wegschmeißen, wenn hier das Mainboard kaputt geht.
Ja. So, das schmeiß ich mal auf die Erde.
Das brauchen wir eh nicht.
So, in der Mitte, da ist er.
Das Ding ist wirklich klein hier.
Guck dir mal.
Wirklich kleine
Kiste. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Verpackungskram.
Wir haben, äh,
was
ist das?
Was ist, was ist das?
Ein SATA-Kabel? Das sieht nicht aus wie ein SATA-Kabel.
Ah!
Ja, jetzt
erkennt man es. Das ist ein SATA-
Stromkabel.
Aber nur
einen? Ne, wait a minute.
Das ist ein SATA und ein SATA-Strom
in so einem Mini, Mini?
In so einem Mini?
Das ist doch bestimmt nicht standardkonform, oder?
Leute.
Das ist doch bestimmt nicht standardkonform für SATA.
Haha. Schön, schön,
schön mit Heißkleber zusammengepappt.
Ich will zusätzlich
eine normale anbringen.
Ich will die SATA und eine normale SSD anbringen.
Okay, das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
gleich noch.
Dann haben wir ein Stromkabel.
Das brauche ich nicht. Da habe ich hier schon eins liegen.
Daneben, man sieht es nicht. Aber da,
da hinten, hier so, da liegt eins.
Dann
haben wir einmal ein HDMI. Das brauche ich auch nicht.
Habe ich bei der Capture Card dabei. Aber vielleicht nehmen wir auch das.
Dann haben wir hier einen Stand.
Ein paar Gummifüßchen.
Ein,
eine VESA-Halterung.
Das ist natürlich cool, dass die dabei ist.
Die kann ich dann nämlich direkt hinten an meinen Fernseher machen.
Das Ding.
VESA-Halterung.
Und ein Netzteil.
Das ist das war's.
Und zwar ist das ein
19 Volt.
Okay, was ganz scheppes.
19 Volt,
6,3 Ampere Netzteil.
Warum muss das ausgerechnet 19 Volt sein?
Dass man da ja nichts anderes dran anschließen kann.
Okay, so. Der VESA-Mount,
den machen wir mal weg. Den brauche ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Kommt hier in die Ecke.
Den Ständer brauche ich jetzt auch nicht.
Kommt hier auch in die Ecke.
So, packen wir mal aus.
Gucken wir mal.
Ist schön klein, das Ding auf jeden Fall.
Fühlt sich gut an.
Fühlt sich Plastik an.
Aber fühlt sich gut an.
Nur mal so Größenvergleich, Leute.
Xbox-Controller
oder Xbox 360
oder nehmen wir den anderen, der hat kein Kabel.
So wie der Kerl
das auch im Video gemacht hat. Guckt mal.
Also das Ding ist klein.
Das ist ein bisschen kürzer.
Oder sagen wir mal ein bisschen...
Der Xbox-Controller
ist ein bisschen länger.
Dafür ist das Ding
oben und unten ein bisschen breiter.
Also es ist relativ klein.
Guckt mal.
Das ist ziemlich genau die Abmaße
von einem Xbox-Controller.
Das ist ziemlich...
Was heißt Staubschicht?
Was meinst du, wie oft ich den Xbox-Controller verwende?
So, was haben wir denn am Start?
Ein Mini-Forum.
Minis-Forum.
Anschlüsse.
Was gibt es da Schönes?
Oh, guck mal.
2,5G-Netzwerk.
Nicht, dass man es da brauchen würde, aber besser als nichts.
Dann haben wir
4x USB, 2x HDMI
und den Stromanschluss.
Und hier irgendwas zum...
Zum Festschließen.
Wenn ich daheim nicht brauche.
Ah, mein Chat wieder.
Das ist ja wieder geil, Alter.
Oh, mein Chat.
Wie soll ich das machen?
Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht.
Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht von ihm.
Er bastelt und wundert sich schon über zwei Sachen.
Oh, nein.
Ich packe eine neue Kiste aus
und wundere mich über Sachen.
Das ist ja mal
unerhört, Alter.
Unerhört.
Da wundert er sich einfach, Mann.
Anzeige ist raus.
Aber richtig.
Also, manchmal...
Chat, manchmal habe ich echt keinen Plan,
was die Leute dazu verleiten,
so Blödsinn zu schreiben.
Was?
Weiß jemand, ob die ersten Chat-GPT-CLI-Tools
irgendwo zum Download gibt?
Ja, klar gibt es das.
Das erste nennt sich
Chat-GPT-Wrapper.
Kannst du eins zu eins so auf GitHub suchen.
Und das andere nennt sich...
Wie hieß das andere?
CLI-Tool...
Warte mal, ich sag's dir.
Das andere
heißt...
AI Ask.
Glaube ich.
AI Ask GitHub.
AI CLI
heißt das andere.
Erinnere mich dran,
wenn ich zurück auf den Linux-Desktop
schalte,
zeige ich es dir.
Wofür planst du denn, diesen Minicomputer
einzusetzen?
Es steht legit eins zu eins im
Stream-Titel.
Wir bauen eine Emulator-Kiste,
die ich dann hinten an meinen Fernseher hänge.
Mit Bartocera-Linux drauf.
Ich hab auch schon ein paar höchst
selbst gerippte ROMs.
Zum ausprobieren später.
Und...
Dann kommt die hinten bei mir
an den Fernseher. Das Gute ist, dass da eine VESA-Halterung
dabei ist, hinten am Fernseher.
Mit dem Controller. Und dann werde ich ein bisschen...
Der Sting kann angeblich
rauf zu Switch emulieren.
Richtig gut.
Wo ist der preislich? Also wenn du es im
Originalshop kaufst, geht es bei
550€ los.
Ohne RAM und ohne
CPU. Äh, nicht ohne CPU.
Schwachsinn. Ohne RAM und ohne SSD.
CPU ist drinne.
Die 32... Also das ist die
32G RAM,
512G SSD-Variante.
Die kostet im Shop 800€.
Und bei Amazon 850€.
...
Am einfachsten ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man sich selbst
so ein No-Profile RAM
und M2 SSD kauft,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
die kleine Variante. Aber so viel teurer ist es
nicht. Der Erda hat 2,5G.
Weil nicht das man es brauchen würde. Es ist aber ganz praktisch,
wenn man über Samba
beispielsweise Isus
selbst, nur selbst erstellte, selbst gerippte
Isus natürlich, rüberkopieren will.
Oder die gesamte
NES, äh, die gesamte
N64 Collection mit
50 Games. Die ist auch glaube
nur irgendwie, weiß ich natürlich
nicht wie groß die ist, aber die ist auch nicht so groß.
So, also
gucken wir mal. Wo geht das auf?
Was haben wir hier? Einmal Lüfter.
Das ist Metallgitter, das finde ich
schon mal ganz gut. Seriennummer
das ist
H12
CAM.
Ist auch ein bisschen doofe Seriennummer, aber gut.
So.
Dann machen
wir das mal auf, weil
ich will ja noch eine SSD. Wo habe ich denn meine
SSD überhaupt?
Wo hab ich die hin? Wahrscheinlich im Schrank noch.
Ich will noch eine SSD reinmachen.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube die Schrauben sind hier drunter irgendwo.
Boah, das ist natürlich doof
hier, das kriegt man ja kaum ab.
Das ist, das ist blöd. Deswegen
sind da auch, guckt mal Leute, deswegen sind
da auch noch extra Füßchen dabei.
Falls man die abreißt.
Äh, du suchst
ein bisschen Hardware für Event
Infra. Was ist denn?
Ist das ein Tool oder meinst du
irgendwie sowas wie
irgendwelche Message, Message
Bus Sachen oder so. Event Infra
sagt mir gar nichts. Und brauche
was als Steam Cache.
Also das Ding hat einen M2 Slot
und hat auf jeden Fall ordentlich Dampf.
Aber ich glaube, ich glaube du
brauchst, achso Front I.O. kann ich auch noch zeigen.
Ich glaube du brauchst
die Grafik Power von dem Ding gar nicht.
Front I.O. ist
äh
das ist wahrscheinlich Strom
Strom an, Strom aus Anzeige oder so.
Mikrofon
oder Lautsprecher, Mikrofon
USB, ha, ha
USB 4
ganz bestimmt.
Wir wissen genau, dass die korrekte Bezeichnung
nicht USB 4 ist, sondern
USB 4.2
Gen 3x2
C1.X
IEEE I5ac
Obviously
Ha, das sind ja Noobs, die denken einfach
es heißt USB 4.
So und wir haben noch einen
Superspeed 10 Gigabit, ok.
Alles klar.
Ok, mal gucken, dass wir das jetzt aufkriegen
ohne es komplett, komplett kaputt
Oh, das geht aber wirklich schwierig ab.
Ok, ich glaube das ist nach einmal
abziehen, RIP.
Aber wir haben ja, wir haben ja
wobei, es geht.
Aber wir haben ja Ersatz, Ersatzpads.
Oh, ich dachte da sind die, ja doch, da sind die
Schrauben drunter, hier ist eine Schraube drunter.
Das ist natürlich doof gemacht, dass man hier
unten drunter mit an die Schraube drankommt.
Guck mal, hier ist die Schraube drunter.
Das ist, das ist schon
ziemlich pilpega.
Weil wenn, also das kannst du
mit dem Ding, das kannst du
das kannst du drei, vier mal machen
dann ist das Teil im Arsch.
Mit dem Föhn den Kleber erwärmen.
Exzellent, aber das ist Gummi.
Ich weiß nicht, was da zuerst
Probleme macht.
Gummi oder der Kleber.
Schraube einfach
nicht mehr einbauen.
Jetzt für den Stream werde ich es eh
offen lassen.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, vielleicht,
vielleicht wenn man da mit dem Schraubendreher
drunter geht, geht es einfacher ab.
Naja, nimmt sich, nimmt sich nichts.
Ach, der geht besser ab.
Guck mal, der geht wirklich, der geht besser ab.
Ah.
Man muss das mit dem Plastik unten drunter abreißen.
Man muss da einmal richtig drunter greifen,
dann geht es auch besser.
Jetzt habe ich, guck, hier ist jetzt gar kein Plastik-Shit
drauf, hier ist noch Plastik-Shit drauf.
Ok, mal gucken, ob meiner,
ob das hier passt.
Nope.
Gucken wir mal, ob der passt.
Wo habe ich denn meinen Schraubschrauber?
Schraubi-Schrauber.
Wo ist denn mein kleiner, kleiner
Schraubendreher hin?
Der ganz kleine, nicht? Der...
Ah, manchmal finde ich meinen Scheiß
nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich an der Werkzeugwand.
Ok, das funktioniert nicht.
Hier komme ich nicht mit rein.
Ich, ich hole mal kurz, ich hole mal kurz was.
Wir brauchen da drin bestimmt noch
mehr Schrauben.
Wie blöd.
Naja, ein paarmal klebt das schon noch, ein paarmal klebt das
noch, aber ich glaube drei bis viermal, dann ist,
dann ist es vorbei.
Ja, jetzt geht das.
Hallo? Alter, das ist aber ganz schön
fest, Mann. Hm.
Ok, ich glaube, ich muss mal wirklich
was anderes holen, so kommt man da nicht gescheit ran.
Gerade mal wieder aufräumen.
Ich hole mal, ich hole mal was ordentliches.
Oh, jetzt habe ich
ein bisschen zu sehr das Ding hier auf den Tisch gehauen.
So, packen wir mal aus.
So, das Ding könnten wir
wahrscheinlich gleich gebrauchen zum Abmachen.
Und eventuell so ein Teil.
Ich brauche mal was zum Ablegen.
Was mir, was mich
im Stream
ein bisschen Platz hat.
So.
Dann gucken wir mal,
was braucht man da für irgendwas kleines.
Weißt du?
Ja, das funktioniert gut.
Gut.
So, das muss ich mal kurz hier rausnehmen, weil
die Dinger sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ziemlich,
ziemlich fest.
Aber jetzt, jetzt geht's.
Zack.
Deswegen mag ich übrigens dieses Silikon.
Das, warum ist denn da was Blaues noch
dran? Guckt mal.
Weil irgendwie da rein
Silikon oder so.
Ja, ich spiegel mir hier laufend.
Jetzt ist der Plastikscheiß darüber und die Schraube kommt
nicht raus, Mann. Okay.
Weg mit dem Handbuch.
So, was haben wir denn hier? Wir haben eine
SSD, die witzigerweise
ein
Passivkühler oben drauf gebunden hat.
Was da für eine M2
SSD drin ist. Vielleicht
können wir das ab, vielleicht, also wenn wir Glück
haben, können wir das
von unten sehen. Ich würde
ungern den
Passivkühler abmachen.
Okay, wer ist high IQ
und findet raus,
was das für eine SSD ist, Leute?
Wer ist, wer
kriegt das raus?
WD Blue, weil das Ding Blue ist.
Kingston,
woher weißt du das?
Woher? Das redest du
jetzt einfach, oder?
Okay, jetzt hat jeder, jeder mal irgendwas gesagt.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach nach, was
das für eine SSD ist.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach nach, was das für eine SSD
ist.
Erstmal geben wir das von da unten
ein. 2072
20,
nee, nee, 2027
Dazu
findet man gar nichts. Und das
da oben ist
E18
Alles klar.
Nee, dazu findet man
ja mal gar nichts.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das für eine ist.
Ist mir auch egal. Ich mache jetzt
den Passivkühler auf jeden Fall nicht ab.
Vielleicht findet man was zu
V
minus 0. Aha.
Nee, das ist
das PCB.
Google sagt Kingston.
Nach was hast du gegoogelt?
Nee, ich mache den Kühler nicht runter.
Kühler nicht runter.
Gut, also SSD, keine Ahnung, was
das für eine ist. Werden wir gleich rauskriegen.
So, wir haben zweimal RAM drinnen.
Kingston RAM auf jeden Fall. Also,
ich meine, wenn die Kingston RAM
drinnen haben, wäre es vielleicht
auch eine Kingston SSD, aber
keine Ahnung. Man, man weiß
das nicht.
Scroll mal hoch, wurde schon verlinkt?
Ja, tatsächlich?
Die Farbe passt schon mal.
Aber ich meine, das können von
also, die Farbe passt gut.
Aber von den Nummern her ist es halt
nichtssagend.
Aber gut, wahrscheinlich
ist es die. Wahrscheinlich ist es die.
Zweites Bild ist von der Rückseite.
Ja, doch.
Doch, das wird die wahrscheinlich sein.
Ja, ja.
Ja, das ist die.
Dass die Nummer ein bisschen variieren, kann schon
sein. Das ist die.
Ich gehe schon mal stark
davon aus, dass die das ist.
Wir können es nachher
auslesen, das stimmt.
Okay.
Also, iPhone Kamera.
Gut, also haben wir
das hier. Dann ist das
hier einmal WLAN,
würde ich sagen.
Einmal WLAN.
Dann haben wir hier,
RAM.
Und zwar, was für RAM haben wir?
Kingston RAM.
Steht da irgendwas Interessantes drauf?
Es müssen 2x 16G
sein. Erkenne ich aber
jetzt nicht. Ach, da oben hier. 16.
DDR4
wahrscheinlich.
DDR4 gehe ich jetzt mal einfach
von aus. Ich glaube, das stand da auch dabei.
So.
Wie kriegt man da jetzt eine SSD rein?
Ah, hier unten. Guck mal, hier unten kommt die SSD rein.
Muss ich das ausbauen, um die SSD
einzubauen? Dazu gucken wir
jetzt tatsächlich doch mal ins Handbuch.
Ob da was zu drinnen steht.
Also, China-Chinesen-Handbuch.
Bla, bla, bla.
Airvents.
Anschlüsse.
Aufschrauben.
Do it yourself SSD.
Gut. Das ist
für die M2 SSD.
Ach, ne. Hier oben kommt die
SSD rein. Nicht unten drunter. Guck mal.
Die SSD kommt hier oben drauf.
Do it yourself
HDD. Führen Sie
die beiden Befestigungslöcher an
der Seite der 2,5 Zoll
HDD-Festplatte in die
Schnallen der Festplattenhalterung ein.
Ja, alles klar.
Jetzt ist nur die Frage,
wie man das anschließt.
Ah, guck mal da.
Das da. Schaut mal hier.
Das da oben.
Das da oben. Da kommt das
wohl rein, hä?
Hier. Hier, da.
Ich glaube, so rum.
Alter, das ist ja mal beschissen,
ey.
Das ist ja mal mega beschissen. Wie soll man das dann
reinkriegen? Da haben sie sich was
ausgedacht, die China-Chinesen, man.
Was ist das?
Gleich hab ich's geprägt.
Okay, ich hab's.
Okay, das ist genau für einmal reinstecken
gemacht, hier. Einmal
reinstecken und nie wieder rausmachen.
Okay, das ist der SATA.
SATA-Kram.
Dann hol ich mal kurz die SSD.
So, passt mal auf.
Ähm.
Was?
Ähm, ich hab
was gefunden. Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass ich
das, dass ich sowas am
Start habe. Und zwar,
das machen wir nicht. Ich sag's euch gleich.
Guckt mal, was ich noch gefunden hab.
Eine 2,5 Zoll
Festplatte.
Die soll da rein. Da hab ich meine Zweifel,
dass das passen würde.
Die machen wir da,
ich sag's schon, ich sag's gleich, die machen wir da nicht rein.
Aber die, die würde doch im Leben,
im Leben
würde ich doch hier keine 2,5 Zoll
Festplatte mehr reinkriegen.
Guck mal, die Festplatte ist, die Festplatte
ist größer als das gesamte Gehäuse.
Echt, ist das eine 3,5 Zoll?
Ihr habt recht, das ist eine
3,5 Zoll. Die ist bloß einfach
ein bisschen kleiner. Die ist bloß
nicht so hoch. Die ist, die ist einfach nur kleiner.
Okay. Na gut.
Ne, dann hab ich doch keine 2,5 Zoll.
Aber, ich hab ne SSD
und die kommt da rein.
Und die SSD muss ich vorher
Ah, hier, guck mal, hier. Das sind die,
das sind die Löcher, wo man das einführen soll.
Gachibas.
So funktioniert das. Easy.
Guck mal, da kannst du gar nichts großartig
verkehrt machen. Und jetzt,
und jetzt kannst du hier neben fest schrauben. Ja, das ist ja
easy. Das kannst du, da machst du, da machst du
wirklich nichts verkehrt.
Da kannst du, da kannst du wirklich nichts verkehrt machen.
Da kannst du wirklich nichts verkehrt machen.
Ich will die SSD aber vorher noch mal kurz
Wipen,
weil es könnte sein, dass dort
noch, ähm,
irgendwas bootbares drauf
ist. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
was da drauf sein könnte. Deswegen will ich
zumindest mal, äh, MBR
die Dehn. Das ist nicht,
das ist gefälligst, wobei wir
booten eh von USB, also ist das
eigentlich auch egal.
Egal, ich dehn dies mal schnell. Ich muss nur mal
kurz gucken, ob ich hier nicht ne,
ob ich irgendwo so ein Adapter hier noch habe.
Also ich hab welche, ich weiß bloß nicht wo.
2,5 Zoll
äh,
nicht 2,5 Zoll, doch 2,5, also
SSD, SATA SSD
auf
USB.
Irgendwo hier hab ich sowas.
Weiß bloß nicht wo.
Hm.
Hier ist es nicht.
Wo könnte ich denn sowas haben?
Jede Menge USB-Sticks.
Nice.
USB-Sticks.
Kartenleser.
Aha, aha.
Aber kein,
ja, ist natürlich blöd.
Wo hab ich irgendwo nen
Adapter? Leute, ich muss noch mal kurz
an den Schrank, ich muss noch mal kurz an den Schrank
gucken, ob ich nen USB,
oder vielleicht hier unter, unterm Tisch,
bei irgendeiner Ablage hier,
weil wenn wir basteln, brauchen wir so Dinge öfters
mal. Ne, ist nicht so.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Sieht nicht so aus, als wär hier was drinnen.
Raspberry Pi brauchen wir jetzt
ganz bestimmt nicht. Ein ESP32
brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht. Okay, ich muss mal kurz
an den Schrank. Ich hab,
ich hab auf jeden Fall noch welche.
Keine M2, doch,
guck mal.
M2, beides. Kommt ne M2
rein und so eine, weil ich noch übrig hab.
Ich mein, besser als dass der Kram bei mir
im Schrank vergammelt, oder?
Secure Erase geht schneller.
Ey, ich muss da nicht Secure
Erase. Ich will ja nur, dass das Ding direkt
von USB bootet und nicht von der eingebauten Platte.
Und damit ich das löschen kann, muss ich's
irgendwie anschließen. Ich guck mal kurz
in den Schrank. Ich hab davon.
Siehste?
Haben wir doch.
Zack.
Aha.
Dann schließ ich das mal kurz bei mir an den
Rechner an.
Und formatier das ne Runde an der VM.
Dürft ihr mir sogar zugucken.
Mein...
Zack.
Ach ja, weil irgendjemand ne Frage hatte, wie
die Tools hießen. Also einmal ist das hier.
AICLI.
Das ist für GitHub Code.
CodePilot in der Shell.
Und
das andere ist
ChatGPTWrapper.
Das hier.
Das sind die zwei Tools,
die ich euch grad gezeigt hab.
Chat, habt ihr wieder Haare
so erkannt?
Der Chat erkennt
wieder heute Haarrisse im Mainboard.
Ich seh's schon kommen.
Das letzte Mal war auch
schlimm, Mann.
Haarrisse im Mainboard. Ich weiß doch.
Ich hab meinen Rechner auf die Seite
gelegt. Da kamen die Leute. Max,
du kannst deinen Rechner doch nicht auf die Seite
legen. Haarrisse im Mainboard.
Nice,
Pipiga. So,
Connect zur VM.
Excellent.
Noch lachst du. Ja,
ich bin nämlich auf dem PC.
Auf dem PC, wo
ich die Haarrisse
angeblich hatte.
Der ist noch nicht einmal abgestürzt.
Fdisk-l
devsdb. Was haben wir denn da?
465.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich richtig.
Ähm,
wie ging das nochmal?
Wie ist das denn da drauf?
Zum Auslesen.
HDPARM.
SDB. Ja, ja.
Ist gut.
Was ist das? HDPARM-V?
Ach, kacke.
Wie kann man nochmal Hersteller und Gedöns
auslesen lassen?
Vendor
und so weiter.
HW-Info. Ach, Minus-L
war es.
Missing
Door.
Ging das mit HDPARM
nicht auch?
HW-Info?
Ich weiß, was es für eine SSD ist.
HW-Info.
Okay.
HW-Info, auch gut.
HW-Info, devsdb.
What the hell?
Was? Ach,
Minus-L?
Ne.
Chat, ihr habt genauso wenig Ahnung wie ich.
Es kann auch sein, dass es mit dem
USB-Adapter gar nicht funktioniert.
Ah.
Exquisite.
Devsdb.
Device.
Model. Siehste? Linux.
Linux-Beste.
Model. Vendor.
Okay, das ist von dem USB.
Von dem USB-Adapter.
Machen wir das gleich wieder weg.
Also gut, dann
HW-Info.
Minus-Minus-Disk.
Geht nicht. Ich hab's jetzt schon wieder.
Okay, komm, wir probieren's jetzt nochmal aus.
HW-Info, Minus-Minus.
Devsdb.
Ah!
Oh, Gru!
Okay, also, was ist es denn?
Es ist...
Moment.
Ach, das sind alle Disks jetzt, oder wie?
Das sind alle Disks.
Okay, das hier oben ist das Interessante.
Da sieht man nix dazu.
Z-RAM?
USB?
J-Chron Mikro?
Ja.
Das ist es, das ist die, das ist die hier.
Das ist die.
So, Mikron.
Ne, das ist die, das ist der USB-Adapter.
Ach, scheiß drauf. Weil SDB ist auf jeden Fall die richtige.
So, jetzt komm, wir fragen mal.
Chat, Chat, Chat,
GPT.
How to clear
MBR on Linux?
Off SSD.
How to clear
SSD
To clear the MBR
Ja.
Auf Chat-GPT. Gib Gas, Mann!
Ich mein, ich weiß,
wie's geht. Ich will wissen, was Chat-GPT macht.
Du machst einfach, ähm,
die ersten, machst einfach die ersten
vier, vier, also normalerweise
512 MB, aber du machst
die ersten vier MB
einfach mit Nullen und gut ist. Okay.
dd if dev0
of devsdx
Ja, okay.
bs446 count-1
Okay. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir machen SDB
und machen allerdings, äh,
Blocksize 4M. Oh, bam.
Zack.
Und jetzt ist, jetzt ist alles gut.
Schauen wir mal, was der erkannt hat.
Ähm,
devsdb
Da ist gar nix drauf, ne?
Und fdisk ist auch der Meinung,
da tut sich nix. Ne, da ist, da ist
gar nix. Na gut.
mkfs
mkfs ext4
def... Alter, ich kann nicht schreiben.
defsdb
Und machen neues Filesystem und dann hängen wir das in die
Kiste rein. Gut.
Jetzt haben wir das Ding gelöscht.
Also gelöscht? Gelöscht haben wir es nicht wirklich.
Aber wir haben es jetzt so gemacht,
dass es so aussieht
als wärs leer.
Wenn die SSD bzw. Adapter trimmen
können, kannst du noch mit BLK
Discard schnell... Alter, der Chat ist
BLK Discard
Chat ist heute wieder
high-IQ. BLK Discard?
Discard
minus F, Def, SDB.
Hey, Operation
und Support. Nope. Kannst nicht.
Egal.
Weg damit. Zack.
So, Capture Card wieder anschließen
an dem Port. Wobei, Capture Card.
Können wir gleich anschließen.
Weil, dann muss ich das eh bewegen.
Äh, Connect
to Host.
Okay, Capture Card ist wieder connected.
Mal gucken, ob die Capture Card funktioniert.
Yep. Nice.
Alles klar. Switchen wir mal auf die Kamera.
Und
bauen die SSD ein.
Account macht das nur für einen Block.
Korrekt. Also, Block Size
4M sind 4.006
9 Spite. Und das Ganze
nur einmal. Wenn du das Count weglässt,
macht das für das ganze Device.
Gut.
Also, jetzt sollen wir was machen.
Also, am besten ist,
macht es einen Unterschied, wie rum der Deckel
draufkommt?
Das ist, glaube ich, relativ
egal, wie wir den Deckel
draufmachen.
Also, muss man mal kurz überlegen.
Die...
Warte mal. Wie rum?
Ich muss gucken, dass ich es richtig rum reinmache.
Also.
So. Okay.
Und jetzt...
Ja, ich würde
sagen, das muss dann so rein.
Also, sprich...
Im Prinzip.
So, hä?
Oder nicht?
Doch. So. Easy.
Gucken, dass es dran ist. Hier unten ist auch alles drin.
So. Jetzt machen wir die SSD
wieder rein.
Nein, das ist ein Mini-Forum.
Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehe. Ich bin hier gerade am Basteln
und gucke nur ab und zu mal auf den Chat.
Ähm...
Müsst ihr das nochmal
schreiben?
Also, das ist ein Mini-Forum.
Das ist kein Nook. Das ist ein Mini-Forum.
Um 690.
Oh, Leute.
Ich habe mein
Antistatik-Armband vergessen.
Jetzt ist... Jetzt ist alles
verloren.
F.
Jetzt ist vorbei.
Jetzt neuen PC kaufen.
Ich meine, ich hätte sogar eins, ja?
Ich glaube, bei diesem iFixit ist eins
dabei. Ja? Könnt mal...
Könnt mal... Also, wir machen es... Wir machen es
nicht so, wie, ähm...
Wie hieß... Wie... Wie...
Wie hieß diese YouTube-Seite nochmal?
Die dann einfach gesagt hat,
so, jetzt haben wir unser Antistatik-Armband an
und alles ist gut.
Also, man muss das irgendwo dran machen.
Am besten irgendwie so an die... An die Heizung
hier unten oder so. Aber, scheiß drauf.
Ganz im Ernst. Verge war das.
Genau.
Lass mal hier wieder rein.
Gut. Alles gut. Passt.
Sitzt, passt,
wackelt und hat Luft. Hätte meine Oma
jetzt gesagt dazu.
Okay, gut.
Also, ganz... So richtig gut
passen tut es irgendwie nicht, aber...
Hab ich...
Ich muss mal gucken. Nicht, dass
ich es jetzt irgendwie blöd dran mache und das ist
doch... Und die Orientierung spielt
doch eine Rolle. Kann ja sein.
Nicht, dass... Nee, weil wir jetzt
nochmal abmachen wäre blöd, ne?
Nee, die Orientierung
spielt echt keine Rolle.
Das ist exakt
symmetrisch
unten.
Hi Max, kenne dich seit 5 Jahren
nur von... Jetzt hab ich dich bei Twitch entdeckt.
Mach weiter so, feier deine Videos.
Schön, dass du deinen Weg hierher gefunden hast.
Pogu.
Also, es macht auch überhaupt keinen Unterschied,
wie ran ich es mache. So kann ich es
nicht machen. So kann ich es nicht machen.
Ich kann es jetzt nur noch so rum machen.
Aber so wirklich gut passen?
Na doch.
Passt doch eigentlich. Ist doch eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Ah, okay.
Nee, passt.
Das ist wirklich schlecht.
Zufrieden bin ich mit dem Sitz.
Mit dem Sitz nicht.
Leute, wir müssen das gerade nochmal... Ich mach das gerade nochmal
ab, das Kabel.
Vielleicht ist es doch nicht egal, wie rum
das draufkommt.
Vielleicht ist es doch nicht egal.
Wollen wir nochmal kurz
ab?
Oh, pass auf, das
kackt mir. Das geht mir jetzt kaputt, wenn ich es abmache.
Okay, vergiss es.
Es geht gar nicht mehr ab.
Doch, geht. Geht noch ab, ohne dass ich es abreiße.
Ähm, mal kurz gucken.
Also, so passt es.
So passt es besser.
Wobei, nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach schon von Anfang an
nicht so hundertprozentig.
Moment,
das ist doch nicht symmetrisch.
Aha, wartet mal.
Okay, so ist es.
Ich glaube, so muss es.
So muss es.
So muss er.
Alles gut.
Okay.
So muss das Ding, weil
hier vorne ist es flach
und hier ist es sonst nirgendwo flach.
Alles klar.
Okay, das ergibt...
Was ist denn das da hinten?
Das ergibt Sinn.
Ja, ich hätte mir vielleicht mal merken sollen,
wie ich das, wie ich den Kram
auf und zu gemacht habe.
Ich glaube, das ist WLAN.
Das ist WLAN und Bluetooth hier auf diesem
Ding.
Okay, dann machen wir das
gerade mal wieder dran.
Okay, SSD ist dran.
Theoretisch könnte man die SSD wahrscheinlich einfach
irgendwie so reinlegen oder so, aber das machen wir nicht.
Zumachen müssen wir eindeutig so rum.
Es geht ja nur in eine Richtung.
Oh, der Sound ist vorbei.
Moment, was hatten wir eben für einen Sound?
Okay.
Schnell im Wort nachschauen.
Hi-Fat-Idee.
Wir haben doch das Wort.
Wobblords.
Twitch.
Wir gucken jetzt im Stream nach, wie rum ich es aufgemacht habe.
Macht habe.
Chat ist wieder sehr schlau heute.
So.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Okay, wie rum, wie rum habe ich es aufgemacht?
Mal gucken, ob man das irgendwie erkennt.
Wo ist vorne?
Hier ist der Einschalter und hier ist,
hier ist das Gitter.
Hier ist dieses, ne, wo ist denn was?
Ich erkenne das gerade nicht.
Wo ist der Aufkleber?
Der Aufkleber.
Der Aufkleber ist, der Aufkleber ist da.
Okay, das ist, das ist, das ist die Seite, wo das Modellding drinne steht.
Achte auf die Seite mit dem Klebestreifen.
Genau, genau.
So.
Okay, das, ich sehe es ja eigentlich schon.
Die Ecke, okay, hier ist, hier ist das mit dem Streifen.
Hier ist das mit dem Streifen.
Moment.
So.
Und der Kleber ist da oben.
Okay, Leute, ich hatte es richtig.
Ich habe, ich habe es richtig.
Ich habe es richtig rekonstruiert.
Alles klar, ich weiß, wie Rumpf, ich weiß, wie Rumpf kommt.
Mit dem, ja, der Kleber ist unten an dem, okay, alles klar.
Also, so rum kommt es, guckt, so exakt so hatten wir es.
Also, hier unten, hier unten ist das Ding mit dem, hier unten ist das Teil mit dem, ey, man sieht es nicht richtig.
Hier ist das, das Ding mit dem Seriennummernteil und so, dann passt das.
Okay, also, dann.
Dann muss die SSD jetzt hier irgendwie rein.
Ne, warte mal.
Muss es ja im Endeffekt.
Soll ich die SSD noch festschrauben?
Ich meine, man könnte die SSD noch festschrauben.
Das Problem ist.
Ähm.
Ich brauche eine Schraube dafür.
Ich habe doch, habe ich hier irgendwie eine?
Lasst mal kurz, lasst mal kurz checken.
Immer festschrauben.
Das ist ja nicht so als.
Mal gucken, ob das passt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich habe jetzt irgendeine genommen, die hier lag.
Okay, scheint zu passen.
Oh Gott, guck mal.
First, first try.
Richtige Schraube gefunden.
Oh shit.
Zwo.
Mann, das ist ja drei, drei, drei D-Chests, Alter.
Dass du hier das Ding eingebaut kriegst.
Es gibt wieder Haarrisse im Mainboard.
Ja, okay.
Also so, so rum, so rum muss das Ding, so rum muss das rein.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Jetzt passt es.
Jetzt kommt die Schraube noch hier rein.
Ein bisschen draufdrücken muss, dass es funktioniert.
Gut.
Excellent.
Alles sitzt.
Alles passt.
Das kommt auch hier rein.
Und zu.
Gut.
Zack.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Alles klar.
Jetzt passt es auch.
So, Schrauben-Night.
Ich werde jetzt nicht so fest schrauben.
Einfach mal ein bisschen.
Also so, dass ich sie wieder abkriege, falls ich es nochmal aus irgendwelchen Gründen aufmachen
muss.
Wo ist die Schraube hin?
Ach da.
Die sehe ich von hier nicht.
Ihr seht die.
Ich stehe ja hier.
Die sieht man nicht gescheit.
Ja, man sieht das.
Man sieht das nicht gescheit von hier.
Alter, was ist denn mit der Musik los?
Übertreibt es ja mal total.
Okay, nice.
So, wir pappen jetzt.
Also, ich verlasse mich einfach mal drauf, dass ich alles richtig gemacht habe.
Ja?
Ja.
Noch, noch pappen sie.
He doesn't know.
He lacks critical information.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich nicht alles richtig gemacht.
Okay.
Passt!
So, zu ist.
Fertig.
Alles eingebaut.
Excellent.
Können wir anschalten.
Auch geht's.
Netzteil.
Du du du du du.
Achso, wir müssen ja noch eine Linux USB Server.
Okay.
Stick machen. Aber erstmal booten
und gucken, ob die Capture Card funktioniert.
Zack.
Zack. Und einmal
Strom. Wollt ihr wissen, was das Ding für
einen Stromverbrauch hat? Soll ich mal anschließen hier?
Ich hab ja so ein Teil da dran. Können wir gucken,
was das für einen Stromverbrauch hat.
Also ich hab ja...
Ah ne, ihr seht's ja noch. Ich hab hier dieses Teil, wo man
gucken kann.
Falls das hier reinpasst, während das
andere drin steckt.
Ja, gerade so.
Gerade so.
Ich glaube, wenn ich es hier so hinschiebe, dann seht ihr es.
Ja. Erstmal anschließen.
Vorher Capture Card.
Capture Card connecten.
Die machen wir hinterm
Stuhl lang.
Dass ich nicht
drüber falle. Ich kenn mich
bei sowas. Muss dann nämlich
vorne rum gleich die
Tastaturen so vielleicht
dran stöpseln.
HDMI.
Oder HDMI, wie das
die coolen Leute nennen.
Was kostet das Ding?
Zwischen
550 Euro
und
850 Euro.
Das ist nicht die billigste
Kiste, aber du kannst dann alles emulieren, bis
rauf zur Switch.
Wie sieh, kurzes
Kabel. Ich nehm doch ein anderes HDMI.
Ich nehm doch ein anderes
HDMI-Kabel.
Wie sie...
Wie sie länger.
Das ist das, was dabei ist bei der Capture Card.
Ich hab noch richtig lange HDMI-Kabel.
Da muss ich aber einen Schrank aufmachen
und mal gucken.
Ich hab ja mal hier in letzter Zeit an Weihnachten rum
aufgeräumt.
Und ich hab jetzt alles soweit sortiert, dass ich den Kram
relativ schnell finde.
15 Watt idle. Ja, mal gucken.
Ich weiß es nicht. Probieren wir mal aus.
Alter, geh auf.
So. Schon besser.
Es dürfte jetzt ungefähr
so 1,5 Meter
HDMI-Kabel sein, damit
kommt man klar.
HDMI out, HDMI
in.
Zack. Alles.
Gut, dann
schalten wir mal um.
Schalten wir mal um. Auf
Elgato
stellt's. No signal.
Gucken wir mal.
Das ist Premiere. Ich hab diese Capture
Card noch nie benutzt.
Du kannst auch Stream Deck OS auf dem Ding
nutzen. Okay. Na, will ich ja nicht.
Ähm,
also, das ist das erste Mal,
dass ich diese Capture Card verwende.
Gucken, ob die funktioniert.
Premiere.
An ist.
So, ich drück jetzt den Power-Knopf.
Es geht an.
Macht ein bisschen Geräusche.
Und jetzt
hoffe ich, dass ich gleich was sehe.
Oder auch nicht.
Sollte, sollte, ah, oh,
hat sich grad was getan? Nee.
Peak Elgato.
Wait.
Rootet er grad in Windows?
Oh, da ist Windows
voll installiert. Ah.
Ah.
Hey, man kriegt mal
eine Windows-Lizenz damit?
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, eigentlich,
wenn man eine Windows-Lizenz sogar mitbekommt.
Ah.
Okay, wir flashen mal
schnell den USB-Stick.
Clear.
Oh. Ja.
Connect to Stream.
Oh, das legale, das weiß man schon.
Wenn es sich aktivieren lässt,
dann aber wahrscheinlich schon.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier Schönes zu bieten?
Das ist wieder SDB.
Wie viele SDBs habe ich denn noch?
Nochmal wieder SDB. Guck mal, da haben wir jetzt sogar zwei Sachen drauf.
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar gestern schon mal
testweise drauf geflasht.
Wir machen sie jetzt aber trotzdem nochmal.
Okay.
Etcher. Wir verwenden übrigens nicht Etcher,
sondern wir verwenden
USB-Imager.
Ich habe mir das aber gealiast
auf Etcher, weil ich sonst
immer wahrscheinlich
vergesse, wie das Tool heißt.
Right.
Please select the writeable source.
Ach, hier.
Ähm.
Download
Bartosera.
Image.
SanDisk.
120G. Kommt hin.
Verify.
Was ist das für eine Pulle, Alter?
Right.
Vorher entpacken. Nope.
Ah.
Ich bin nicht in der USB-Gruppe.
Okay. Aber das geht mein Alias nicht.
Das ist natürlich bescheuert.
So, zack.
Right.
Boah, Alter.
What the fuck?
Der flutscht.
Alter, der flutscht, der USB-Stick, Mann.
Juuu.
Würde das Ding schon mitmachen,
oder?
Würde mich wundern.
Der USB-Stick ist jetzt erst mal
80 Grad heiß.
Das ging ja mal richtig
zackig gerade.
Nice ist das Flash-Tool.
Liegt aber eher am USB-Stick.
Verified er jetzt, oder was
macht er?
Oder ist er fertig?
Ah, nee. Der ist fertig komplett.
Inklusive Verify ist er dann.
Alter.
Der ist aber mal richtig schnell.
Mal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Ja, wir können der Form
halber noch einen Sync hinterher schmeißen.
Okay, nice.
Mal gucken, ob sich jetzt das Ding mounten lässt.
Mount
Dev SDB
Tja.
Gute Frage.
SDB 2
Mount Dev SDB auf
Okay.
Ich versuche einfach mal
davon zu booten.
Ich glaube dem einfach mal,
dass der schon geflasht hat.
Wir schieben das jetzt einfach mal rein
und ich starte das. Easy.
Gucken wir mal.
Äh, nope. Elgato.
Hello, welcome Windows.
Geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Ja, USB-Stick dran.
Ja, USB-Stick dran
und das Ding wird neu gestartet.
Und ich hoffe,
dass es beim Neustarten
jetzt ordentlich bootet, weil ich weiß nicht,
was ich für einen Knopf drücken muss, um vom USB-Stick zu booten.
No signal.
Nice. GG Eats.
Warum hat das beim Booten
eigentlich kein Signal?
Direkt am Monitor anschließen.
Ne, das muss das Ding schon können.
Das muss das schon checken.
Moment, habe ich es jetzt
ausgeschaltet oder was?
Ne, es ist noch an.
Muss man da irgendwas einstellen
oder so?
Also muss man keine Auflösung einstellen.
Kann man, also man kann Custom Resolution,
machen, aber nicht, dass es...
Ich kann runter bis auf 640
mal 480.
No signal.
Soll ich vielleicht mal doch Game Capture installieren?
Elgato
Game Capture.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, es funktioniert einfach.
Erinnerst du dich
an Slow Boot Times? Ja, das kann durchaus
sein.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass es
Slow Boot Times hat.
Aber so Slow Boot Times,
also man sollte ja zumindest irgendwas
sehen drauf.
Anderen HDMI Port?
Hm.
Können wir tatsächlich mal probieren.
Aber wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich vollkommen egal.
No Signal
gibt es nicht.
Ja gut, wir wissen ja, dass es im Prinzip funktioniert.
Weil
wir haben es ja, wir haben es ja eben in Windows
schon mal gesehen.
Okay.
Ich installiere doch mal Game Capture.
Wer weiß, vielleicht.
Game Capture.
Select your product.
Capture.
Was ist das? HD60X glaube ich.
Windows.
Jojo.
Hieß das Ding nicht früher mal Game Capture?
Die alte gibt es gar nicht
mehr zur Auswahl, oder?
Elgato
Game Capture Software.
Die gibt es nicht mehr. Das heißt jetzt 4K Capture.
4K Capture Utility.
Okay.
4K.
Das Ding macht nix.
Okay.
Dann installieren wir uns das 4K Game Capture Utility jetzt.
Help. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Kann ich das?
Kann ich das nicht ohne Adminrechte?
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Mach mal Adminrechte.
Pass auf, jetzt will er
neu starten gleich.
Game. Ne.
Capture.
Elgato 4K Capture Utility
Elgato 4K Capture Utility heißt das jetzt.
Das ist jetzt neu anscheinend.
No Signal. Okay, geil.
Capture 1080p.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Device.
Ähm.
Was?
Was willst du von mir?
Streamlink Beta?
Streamlink Beta? What?
Sag mal, früher konnte man
noch die Auflösung noch irgendwie umstellen.
Oder bin ich
da jetzt zu pepega für
No Signal?
Das Ding sieht auf jeden Fall anders aus
als früher.
Es gibt, ach Moment, Game Capture
gibt es auch noch?
Warum gibt es da schon wieder tausend verschiedene
Software dafür?
Es gibt das 4K Capture Utility
und es gibt
Game Capture. Aber letztendlich
ist es egal, dass wir den Game
Capture genauso wenig funktionieren.
No Signal.
Okay, ich weiß was, ich stöpsel es einfach mal ab.
Und wieder dran.
Aber wir wissen, wir wissen
ja im Prinzip, My Great Capture, genau
so hieß diese Elgato Krempel immer.
My Great Game, ja erstmal
4K Capture, erstmal alles, erstmal alles
löschen wieder. So.
Also wir wissen ja, dass es im Prinzip
funktioniert.
No Signal. Okay, nice.
Also wir wissen ja, dass es im Prinzip funktioniert.
Ich zieh nochmal, ich zieh einfach nochmal
Strom ab. So, wir müssen jetzt
mal kurz googeln. Kann man mit so einer, kann man mit
der Elgato Karte überhaupt ins BIOS?
Unterstützt die das denn überhaupt?
HD, wie heißt das Ding?
HD 60X
Re...
BIOS
Resolution
Sollte eigentlich
doch gehen. Ich mein, wäre bescheuert, wenn das nicht klappt.
Haben die vielleicht
irgendwie mal so ein Specs oder so
davon? HD 60X?
HD 60X Specs.
Weiß ich nicht.
So, HD 60... Technical
Specifications. Capture Resolutions.
Sehr, sehr,
sehr aussagekräftig. Up to
480p. Ich hab
keine Ahnung, welche Auflösung normalerweise
so ein BIOS hat.
Elgato HD 60
BIOS. Tja,
oder UEFI, oder...
Oh, das regt mich jetzt schon wieder auf, dass ich, ich weiß
jetzt nicht. How do I capture BIOS
Screen? Also, ich
wir können auch die andere
Capture Card. Ich hab ja noch, ich hab ja noch
die alte Capture Card. Also, mit der geht's auf
jeden Fall. So, ich mach
jetzt, ich mach jetzt wieder an.
Mal gucken, ob jetzt,
ob jetzt was passiert.
Ich, ich... Ah!
Okay.
Jetzt geht's einfach, oder wie?
Auch okay.
No Signal.
Alter, die wissen echt nicht, was Sache ist.
So, ich brauch mal ne Maus.
Ich brauch mal ne Maus.
Wo ist die Maus? Alter.
Maus.
Please.
Die steckt unterm Tisch, man.
Krieg ich jetzt meine Maus hier raus?
Ich hab beim...
Jaja, Windows, ist gut. Ich brauch die zweite Maus.
Die steckt am anderen Rechner dran.
Und das Dumme ist, irgendwie hab ich
den Rechner da drauf
gestellt.
So, einfach mal hochgehoben. Geht.
So, Windows will ich da drauf
definitiv nicht installieren.
Deswegen mach ich jetzt ne Maus dran.
Repute das Ding und steck den USB-Stick dran.
Vielleicht muss ich auch die Tastatur dran stöpseln.
Okay. Okay, es ist wirklich relativ,
relativ lag, lag free.
Ich schau mal, ob ich euch umschalten
kann, dass ihr wieder hier ordentlich was seht.
No Signal.
Keckel.
Okay, die Anzei... Leute,
die Anzeige,
die Anzeige in OBS sagt einfach.
Oder man kann nicht beides
kaufen haben, das kann auch sein.
Das was wir machen hier einfach Fullscreen und gut ist.
Minisforum, das
ist der 60...
UM6090.
Wie startet man hier übrigens neu?
Make your computer easier to use.
Make your computer...
Ah, geh weg.
Sag mal, hat das Windows-Setup keinen Reboot-Button
mehr, oder wie?
Ich hab keine Tastatur angeschlossen.
Ich hab eigentlich gehofft, man kann das alles mit nem
Controller machen, wenn ich das vom USB-Stick
gebootet bekomme.
Oh fuck, da muss ich jetzt die Tastatur hier rüber...
Oh fuck, da muss...
Ich brauch mal... Ich brauch ein zweites Set an
Tastatur und Maus. Ich brauch so ne Mini...
Mini-Tastatur und Mini-Maus
für solche Sachen, dass ich nicht immer meine Tastatur
umstöpseln muss.
Weil das fuckt schon ein bisschen ab.
Ich stöpsel jetzt die Tastatur um.
Mann, was willst du machen?
Tastatur...
Okay, Tastatur ist dran.
Kann ich einfach Ctrl-Alt entfernen drücken?
Ne, das geht natürlich nicht.
Das ist einfach.
Shift-10?
Moment, man kann... Seriously?
Man kann das Setup nur noch rebooten
über...
Ne, wie macht man das? Shutdown?
Ich... Nein, ich bin zu dumm
ein Windows-Setup zu rebooten.
Alter, 4?
Ne, Windows-Setup möchte nicht
rebooted werden. Gibt das nicht.
Langes
Ctrl-Alt entfernen. Okay.
Nicht wirklich.
Shutdown.
Minus...
Ja, Slash.
Ja.
Yes.
Okay.
Ah!
So, und jetzt?
USB-Stick dran.
Ah!
Muss ich... Kann ich
irgendeinen Knopf drücken fürs BIOS?
Oh ne, jetzt startet wieder Windows, oder?
Ich hämmere...
Ich hämmere gleich entfernen.
Okay, nochmal neu starten.
Windows, nerv mich please nicht.
Bei der Gelegenheit...
Ich kann jetzt noch nicht mal...
Ich hab jetzt noch nicht mal eine Tastatur, wo ich suchen kann.
Und ich hab kein Handy, um was einzutippen.
Wir testen jetzt...
Wir testen jetzt alles. Okay, Windows, was?
Was war das? Shift-F10?
Shutdown?
R? T? 0?
Was ein Spaß, ey, man.
Das ist... Okay, entfernen, entfernen, entfernen, entfernen.
Meistens ist es entfernen.
Entfernen, F2, F1.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Ah! Guck mal da, ein BIOS.
BIOS.
Boot.
Ein
ABT-IO-Setup.
BIOS-Version.
Okay, was kann man da alles einstellen?
SATA-Controller.
SMU-Options.
Was auch immer SMU ist. System Configuration.
Sustain Power Limit.
Ich glaube, da stellen wir schlicht und ergreifend
gar nichts dran ein.
Hardware-Monitor. Bam!
Smart Fan-Function. Bam!
Ich stell mir auch nichts ein.
S5-RTC-Wake-Up.
Network-Stack-Configuration.
GFX-Configuration.
Ist das das, wie viel Shared-RAM
die Grafikkarte sich zieht, oder?
Security.
Boot.
Fixed-Boot. Okay.
Also die BIOS-Settings sind, glaube ich,
die ziemlich rudimentärsten BIOS-Settings,
die ich jemals gesehen habe.
Du kannst ja legit gar nichts einstellen
in den BIOS.
Gibt es nicht sowas wie Temporäres?
Tempo... Tempo...
Temporäres?
Was, da stand noch was unter GFX?
Nö.
Nur die Buffer-Size.
Die UMA-Buffer-Size.
Aber nicht einfach
Temporär sagen, ich möchte das
booten.
NVMe-USB.
BBS-Priorität.
Okay.
Boot Option 1.
Ist der USB-Stick.
Ich sehe schon, wir müssen gleich
nochmal ins BIOS.
Ach, Boot Override.
Da ist es.
Ah.
Moment, da kann eine SD-Karte rein.
Harddisk.
Und als nächstes
meinetwegen NVMe.
Boot Override. Wir wollen booten.
USB Partition 1.
S.
USB booten.
Please.
Ah, da sind wir.
Oh, es macht einen Sound.
Alter, jetzt übertreibt man nicht.
Mach halt,
mach halt noch lauter, bitte.
Ist ja gut.
Alter, wie kriege ich die Musik wieder leiser?
Oh.
Sekunde.
Windows Mixer.
Okay.
Wir lassen uns von der Musik beschallen.
Viel zu laut.
Okay.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Musik TOS ist.
Weil TOS-Musik dürften die nicht mitliefern.
Okay.
Und wie installiert man das jetzt?
Vielleicht hätte ich mir mal
einen Guide dazu durchlesen sollen.
Okay, ich glaube, ich muss einen Controller
anschließen, Leute. Ich glaube, ich muss einen Controller anschließen.
Zack.
Kurz mal Controller.
Oh, jetzt habe ich es irgendwie geschafft.
Ich habe den Controller.
Wie habe ich es jetzt geschafft,
das bitteschön um das Kabel zu wickeln?
Das ist doch gar nicht möglich.
Das war eben noch aufgewickelt.
Okay.
Live-System ist das doch, oder?
Ja, aber ich will es installieren.
Weil
ich will da kein USB-Stick
für.
Ich habe zwei Festplatten drin.
Okay, wir haben jetzt
einen Xbox-Controller
dran.
Ah, nice.
Okay. Menü.
Wir haben sogar ein Kodi Media Center
am Start. Alles klar.
Das ist gut. Oh, es ist...
Alter, ist der Controller
staubig.
Okay. Kodi haben wir am Start.
Exit.
Kodi braucht man da nicht wirklich, aber
es ist sehr cool, dass es dabei ist.
Ich meine, es sind ja keine Games dabei.
Es sind ja nur irgendwelche Open-Source
Games
dabei, um zu gucken,
dass es funktioniert.
Die dürfen natürlich nichts mitliefern.
Okay, also, was haben wir denn hier?
Game Settings.
Boot into Bar2SerienPress
Start to open the main menu.
Navigate to System Settings.
System Settings.
Okay.
Mein Controller hängt. Es passiert einfach gar nichts gerade.
Und jetzt?
Hallo?
Oh, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Oh shit.
Okay, ich glaube, ich muss das nochmal machen.
Systemeinstellung.
Das hat einfach nur ewig geladen,
eben. Also,
Information, Language,
Englisch, UK,
okay, Zeitzone, Europe,
Berlin,
Kokona, Time Format.
Ich will es ehrlich gesagt
einfach nur...
Ja, auf eine 9. Wir stellen es mal auf Englisch
wieder zurück. Okay.
Install
on New Disk.
Storage Device.
Internal.
Okay, wir haben
Internal zur Auswahl. Ne, Internal ist der
USB-Stick, oder?
Ah, ich muss die Windows, ich muss bestimmt
das Windows noch
ähm
platt machen.
Okay. Install on New Disk.
Jetzt hängt es wieder.
Okay, ich mache jetzt einfach nichts.
Das Menü braucht ein bisschen. Wahrscheinlich,
wenn man das erste Mal das Menü aufmacht, muss
man vom USB-Stick, vom USB-Stick
nachladen. Deswegen werde ich einfach nichts
machen, bis sich das Menü jetzt geupdatet hat.
Network Required.
Okay, das, das ergibt
natürlich...
Warum, warum ist das Network Required?
Um es auf einem neuen Disk zu installieren?
Just, just
asking.
Ähm...
Network.
Da muss ich den Switch erstmal
einschalten. Für den Switch
brauche ich Strom.
Und Strom
muss ich die Lampe
ausmachen. Okay, Switch.
Dann brauchen wir
jetzt noch ein Netzwerkkabel.
Wir können gleich mal
testen, wir können gleich mal
testen, ob das Ding 2,5
G auch erreicht.
Ich stöpsel es mal an einen 10G-Port
ran, RJ540, und gucken, ob es sich
synkt mit 2,5.
Äh?
Es synkt sich auch.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß nicht mit wieviel
kommt man in Barthos Serra auch irgendwie in die
Chef... Also das erste, was ich machen werde, definitiv
ist SSH einschalten.
So.
Ja, das einzige, was ich gemacht habe, ist mir den
Install angeguckt.
Network Required. Okay, Install on New Disk.
Jetzt haben wir es doch.
Passt.
Kannst du direkt in der GUI machen. Nice, werde ich da machen.
Target Device. Hier.
Kingston.
Das ist die On...
Das ist mein USB-Stack.
Ein
UM690
Mini-Forum.
Also, das ist die Onboard-SSD.
Da kommt das drauf.
Target...
Muss ich da irgendwas auswählen?
X86-64 gehe ich mal von aus.
Muss ich auswählen.
Nee, ich hab...
Äh...
Kingston ist die Onboard.
X86-64.
Guck das da.
CTMX500 ist meine SSD.
Alter!
Solution, the fuck?
Hallo, Leute.
Damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Dankeschön.
Für den Pogu-Raid.
Was habt ihr gemacht? Wahrscheinlich habt ihr Warzone gespielt
und rumgeraged.
Jetzt geht's aber los, ja.
So, installieren.
Dann mal kurze Zusammenfassung, was wir hier machen.
Sekunde, Leute.
Wenn so viele neue Leute da sind, muss ich mal kurz
ein bisschen erzählen, was wir eigentlich gerade hier machen.
Ich mach mal kurz
die Beleuchtung wieder an, dass man was gescheites
sieht.
Also, was wir gerade machen, ist folgendes.
Ich switch mal auf die Kamera.
Ich hab mir diesen Mini-PC hier gekauft.
Den ihr jetzt, glaube ich, im Fullscreen
sehen solltet.
Fortnite trainieren, okay.
Pog.
So, also.
Aber auch rumgeraged. Ich will's mal hoffen.
Was anderes hätte ich jetzt auch nicht erwartet.
Es ist krass mittlerweile, was es eigentlich für
Preisgelder schon so in, sagen wir mal so,
ähm,
jetzt, jetzt, äh,
in, im,
wie heißt denn das richtig?
So in der Streaming-Amateurs-Szene gibt.
Ja, da sind ja keine super krassen
ESL-E-Sport-Events.
Also, da tut sich mittlerweile was. Die meisten
Streamer-Turniere haben ja mittlerweile mehr
Preisgelder als irgendwelche
ESL-Finals. Einfach, weil da mehr
Kohle drin ist. Ist schon heftig.
So, also. Was wir hier machen,
ist, ich hab mir einen Mini-PC gekauft. Und zwar
ist es ein,
seht ihr hier, ein, ein Mini-Forums.
Ich kann nicht so wirklich bewegen, weil
da hinten so viel Shit dran ist.
Ähm, ein Mini-Forums-PC.
Ein UM690.
Der hat,
äh, unter anderem
tatsächlich USB4 schon.
Man erkennt's nicht so ganz, aber, ja.
So, da haben wir gerade eine SSD eingebaut.
Beziehungsweise eine M2-SSD ist drin.
Eine normale 2,5 Zoll-SSD ist drin.
Und das ist ein super
Kiste zum Games emulieren.
Zum alte Konsolen beispielsweise
emulieren. Da kann man
bis hoch, also angeblich, ich hab's noch nicht
ausprobiert, ja. Da kann man angeblich
bis zur Switch emulieren. Was man natürlich
nicht darf. Beziehungsweise
doch. Switch emulieren darfst du.
Du darfst natürlich keine Spiele mit
Kopierschutz auslesen und umgehen.
Und sowas würden wir hier im Stream natürlich nie im Leben
machen. Und natürlich sind alle meine
ROMs rein selbst
gerippt. Ja.
Also diese Kiste hab ich mir gekauft. Ist
eine Kombi-CPU.
Ist ein AMD
Ryzen 6900
HX heißt
das Ding, glaub ich. Ist
eine CPU mit einer Grafikkarte drauf.
Was extrem nice
ist für den Formfaktor. Ich zeige euch
mal zum Vergleich, wie groß das Ding ist.
Guckt mal hier. Da hab ich
meinen Xbox-Controller.
Ich hab tatsächlich den Xbox 360
Controller. Dementsprechend ist der auch ein bisschen
staubig. Guckt mal.
Ähm.
Also das Teil ist
quasi
so groß wie ein Xbox-Controller.
Es ist, es ist. Der Xbox-Controller
ist ein bisschen länger, aber das ist ein bisschen höher.
Es hat ungefähr die Abmaße von einem Xbox-Controller.
Das heißt, es ist relativ
relativ klein. Was
sehr praktisch ist, wenn man nämlich, und das ist das, was ich
damit auch vorhabe. Vielleicht werde ich das auch in einem
Video verwursten. Wenn man das Ding
nämlich hinten an seinem Fernseher montieren will,
kann man das machen. Das hat
Halterung und es hat einen VESA-Mount dabei.
Das heißt, man kann das,
hinten,
hinten an den Fernseher montieren.
Richtig kleine Box. Es hat einen Lüfter
drinnen. Ist sehr leise. Also man hört,
man hört eigentlich gerade, eigentlich
hört man, hört man gar nichts.
Und es ist für mich, was
ich so geguckt hab, so die optimale
Emulatorkiste, wenn man ein bisschen mehr
als Super Nintendo und N64
spielen will. Also was ich vorhabe ist,
ich möchte beispielsweise mal wieder Mario Galaxy
und sowas spielen. Ich will, also ich möchte
tatsächlich bis hoch zu
Switch-Spielen mal ausprobieren.
Aber hauptsächlich will ich natürlich
SNES,
N64, PS1,
PS2, Wii,
vielleicht ein bisschen Wii U
und eventuell auch ein bisschen Switch.
Aber hauptsächlich auch mal bis zu Wii, inklusive Wii.
Und das coole ist, das Ding ist so
leistungsstark, dass du
sogar Wii-Spiele nicht nur emulieren
kannst, du kannst Wii-Spiele
upscalen auf 1080p. Theoretisch
sogar auf 4K, aber ich glaube nicht, dass
die Kiste 4K, 4K Wii-Spiele
machen wird. Und da sehen Spiele wie Super Mario
Galaxy extrem nice aus,
weil Nintendo
die Spiele deutlich, sagen wir mal, hochwertiger
von den Assets produziert hat,
als es auf so einer billigen
Palauflösung im Fernsehen ausgeschaut hat.
Also das ist wirklich
extrem nice, diese Kiste.
Kostet, weil ich weiß, dass die Frage wieder
kommt. Übrigens, für alle, die neu sind,
wenn ihr irgendwas, wenn ihr
irgendwas habt und ich antworte nicht drauf,
schreibt entwupplos mit in Chat, das
übersehe ich das gerade, wenn ich hier am basteln bin,
da am klicken bin, da am machen bin.
Ich habe zwar immer ein Auge auf den Chat, aber
alles sehe ich auch nicht. Joa,
das probieren wir dann auch gleich mal aus.
Aktuell bin ich gerade dabei,
eine ordentliche Oberfläche drauf zu installieren.
Also das ist die Kiste
und wir machen jetzt weiter, würde ich sagen.
Genau, Anschlüsse,
man hat sogar ein 2,5G
Netzwerkport. Das ist
tatsächlich ganz praktisch, wenn man da was
übers Netzwerk drauf kopieren will.
Aktuell verbraucht es idle,
dass ihr auch mal das erkennt, guckt mal.
Idle
12,6 Watt.
Achso, du wolltest sagen, wie teuer, stimmt.
Also, in der
Ausführung, wie ich sie habe, kostet's
800 Euro, beziehungsweise
850 bei Amazon.
Ich kann's euch mal zeigen.
Aber die gibt's auch noch
billiger. Also, wenn man nur
Super Nintendo und N64 emulieren
will, gibt's das Ganze deutlich billiger.
Aber ich will halt alles bis hoch
zur Switch machen. Also, wenn ihr
wirklich nur die ganz alten Konsolen
emulieren wollt, PS1,
SNES, NES
und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen N64,
dann kommt ihr mit der billigsten
50-Euro-Kiste klar.
Ich will halt ein bisschen mehr machen.
So, guck mal, Mini-PC, AMD.
Das ist die neue.
Da kommt ihr auch mit sowas hier, easy.
Für die ganz alten Konsolen
easy. Da könnt ihr wirklich
ganz, ganz billige, kleine
Kisten
nehmen. Also, 50-Euro-PC
reicht für die alten Konsolen. PSP und so
reicht easy aus. Ja, aber wenn man ein bisschen
Wii und vielleicht ein bisschen Wii U
vielleicht sogar mal ein bisschen
Xbox oder so haben will, dann braucht's schon ein bisschen
mehr. So, also, in der
Ausstattung Barebone, also sprich, wenn
ihr selbst RAM kaufen wollt, falls ihr noch RAM
habt, beziehungsweise falls
ihr eine SSD habt, dann
könnt ihr die Barebone-Ausrüstausstattung kaufen.
Das ist dann nur die Grafikkarte
und die CPU und halt das
der Rechner mit Grafikkarte und CPU.
Das ist ja in einem. Das ist ja Grafikkarte
und CPU ist in einem.
Wer wissen will, wie das Ding aufgeschraubt aussieht,
muss ein bisschen zurückspulen im Stream.
Kann sich das ja nachher angucken.
Das haben wir schon alles aufgebaut.
So, und ich hab diese Ausstattung.
32 GB RAM
und 512 G SSD.
Ich hab allerdings noch eine alte
SSD zusätzlich mit eingebaut,
die nochmal 512 G
hat. Also hab ich ungefähr einen Terabyte
SSD-Speicherkrater drinne. Die SSD
kommt, seht ihr ja, die kommt hier oben so
so rein.
Jo.
So sieht's aus.
Ein bisschen Musik anmachen.
Und ihr könnt's entweder hier im
Shop kaufen, da müsst ihr aber noch
Versand drauf rechnen.
Oder ihr geht
bei Amazon und bei
Amazon ist das alles ein bisschen
warum kein Steam Deck für Emulation, weil ich
was haben will, was ich mir hinter dem Fernseher
hänge. Ich weiß nicht,
was ist in dem Steam Deck drinne?
Ich geh davon aus, wahrscheinlich
ist das ähnliche Hardware.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht so großartig unterschiedlich.
Zelda Ocarina of
Time N64. Das läuft
easy. Du kannst hier Ocarina of Time
theoretisch upscaled auf
1440p
spielen. Können wir vielleicht
nachher sogar mal ausprobieren.
Was ist denn im Steam Deck drinne?
Ein
Custom APU.
4 Cores, 8 Threads
und?
Graphics?
Ähm, nee.
Das ist ziemlich
das gleiche eigentlich.
Das ist, also
der Stream Deck hat ein bisschen schlechtere CPU.
Aber
ja.
Also die Kiste hier hat ein bisschen stärkere
CPU als das Stream Deck.
Und Graphics?
Seht ihr irgendwas zu
Graphics?
Wahrscheinlich
ist die Steam Deck Grafikkarte
ein bisschen besser. Also
unterm Strich wahrscheinlich ist
gar kein so großer Unterschied.
Es ist halt schön klein, lässt sich hinter
lässt sich hinter den Fernseher hängen.
Okay.
Weiter geht's.
Wo hab ich meinen Controller hier?
Oh, jetzt geht die Musik
wieder an. Das ist ja wir.
Mal geht die Musik an, mal geht sie aus.
So, also wir installieren das jetzt erstmal.
Wohlgemerkt, ich hab das selbst
benutze das hier, also ich hab das selbst noch nie benutzt.
Ich benutze das zum ersten Mal.
Ja, das ist auch AMD.
Das ist eine AMD APU, quasi
On-Chip
Grafikkarte mit drinne.
Also,
Target Device.
Wir wollen es installieren auf die interne
M2 SSD. Also ich hab zwei
Platten drinne. Das hier ist der USB Stick.
Da sollte man sich jetzt nicht verklingen.
Ich hab zwei Platten drin. Einmal
eine
M2 SSD, das ist die hier unten.
Und hier eine MX500.
Auch nochmal, so mit 512G.
Beziehungsweise, genau genommen
sind es ja keine Gigabyte, sondern
sind ja, sind ja, äh,
was? Gebi-Byte?
Wie auch immer.
Man sagt ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr Gigabyte,
weil Giga ja 1000 ist.
Und nicht 1024.
Aber das wäre zu 6 hätte ich.
Oder Gibi? Gibi
oder Gebi?
Was auch immer. Ehrlich, das sind so Dinger.
Alle Programme
und Tools können es mittlerweile niemand
benutzt.
Höchstens, ich weiß nicht, falls jemand
von euch Fachinformatiker gelernt hat,
Abschlussprüfung bei der IHK gemacht hat,
die fragen so einen Scheiß. Ja, ansonsten fragt
das keiner. Okay, wir installieren es auf der internen
SSD. Unsere Architektur
ist x86-64, ist kein
Raspberry Pi und keine irgendwelche anderen
Single Board Computer.
Are you sure?
Wir sind sure. Working.
Du bist gerade dabei. Gibi?
Okay, ja. Aber es ist
nicht Meebi, sondern Meebi.
Anstatt Mega.
Wer auch immer sich das
ausgedacht hat.
Nice. So, working.
An error occurred.
Ist ja geil.
Klappt schon wieder erste
Sahne.
An error is occurred.
Top.
Klappt ja richtig
gut. Dann installiere ich es mal auf der anderen
SSD. Vielleicht hat er
Probleme mit der M2.
Oder er hat Probleme, wisst ihr was auch
sein kann?
Was ist das für eine Software?
Das ist Batozera Linux.
Das ist ein Live...
Network is required?
Ach, ich...
Leute, ich bin ja auch blöd.
Ich habe den Switch
ausgeschaltet,
weil ich die Beleuchtung einschalten musste,
dass ich es euch auf der Kamera zeigen kann.
Ich habe nicht genug freie Steckdosen.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Kein Wunder, dass ein error occurred ist.
Ich konnte nicht downloaden, weil der Switch aus war.
Okay.
Switch ist gebootet, das Ding hat eine IP.
Install on new disk.
Aber es hat
nice background sound.
So, also select auf
die Kingston SSD. Architecture
are you sure?
Yes, install.
Alter, geh mal nicht auf den Sack,
Mann. Okay, dann
installieren wir es da drauf.
Install.
Was ist denn das?
Ekel.
Besser gesagt, Cake Weight.
Das ist natürlich toll.
Wie gut das funktioniert.
Ja, jetzt übertreibt man nicht.
Reboot.
Meinst du Reboot hilft?
Okay, Reboot.
Wie rebooted man das Ding denn?
Wie gesagt,
ich kenne das.
Security Frontend Developer Options
wird es wahrscheinlich...
Audio Port.
Kodi Settings.
Ja, okay, wer Kodi starten will, kann das da drauf
auch machen. User Interface
Mode Fullscreen.
Information.
Ich will mal meine IP wissen,
falls das möglich
ist, dass ich mich da
per SSH drauf verbinden kann.
Wo finde ich
Network Settings?
Ah ja, 2.141.
Alles klar.
Loggen wir uns mal mit Linux kurz drauf ein.
Aber da ist das Soundtrack
im Hintergrund.
Was mit eingeschaltetem Switch?
Was?
Ne, das müsst ihr ja eigentlich hinkriegen.
Ah, wir probieren es gleich nochmal.
SSH 102.14.
Yes.
Achso, ne.
Bato Serra
Default User SSH
und Default Password.
Bato Serra.
So richtig schreiben kann.
What is the
User and Password? Bato Serra
Linux.
Root und Linux. Okay, da wäre ich jetzt
hätte ich auch so drauf kommen können.
Hey, da sind wir.
So.
Logs.
Install Log. Was hat da
das Install?
Install Log.
Not enough space.
What?
Hä?
Ist ein DD drauf?
Ja, nice. DD ist drauf.
Okay, dann werde ich erst mal kurz die
interne Windows SSD platt machen.
Der kann das
auf den USB-Stick laden.
Das ist gar kein Ding. Der USB-Stick hat noch
Der USB-Stick hat
noch
Der USB-Stick ist komisch
gemountet. User Data.
Ah, ich muss das Storage wahrscheinlich
umstellen.
Ne, okay. Jetzt
kapierst. Der hat das ISO gestartet.
Der hat das ISO gestartet. 1 zu 1 das ISO
gemountet. Und
ähm
nicht den restlichen USB-Stick.
Weil der USB-Stick selbst
ist. Warte mal, wo ist denn das
überhaupt?
Ja, der USB-Stick selbst
Das ist Dings.
Ja, der USB-Stick
selbst hat
Wo ist denn der
USB-Stick überhaupt?
Das ist die SSD.
Das ist der USB-Stick, der aus irgendwelchen
Gründen. Ja.
Das ist meine... Ne, was?
Hä?
Das ist das gemountete?
Ihr habt recht.
Hier, okay.
Das SDA ist die
Das ist die
Windows?
Das ist das Windows-Ding.
Das hier ist USB.
Vermute ich mal.
Sehr weird champ.
Das ist USB.
Und das ist die normale
Das ist die normale
Disk.
Okay.
Nice. Dann werden wir es jetzt so machen.
mkfs
ext4
Wir machen mal die Windows-Partition
platt. Weil das brauchen wir nicht.
dev nvme
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Mach mal
mount
Was?
Welches soll ich mounten?
Ach ne, N1 muss ich machen.
Was soll ich mounten,
Twinkor?
Den Stick?
Warum benutzt du nicht Gpart?
Weil ich per SSH auf dem Live-Linux-System
drauf bin.
So.
Mach einfach alles platt.
Ich meine, ich kann ja nicht wirklich
was kaputt machen.
Okay, nice.
Fdisk.
Das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Okay.
Ne, ich glaube, ich muss einfach das Storage im Menü umstellen.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, woran es liegt, dass es nicht geht.
Guckt mal.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz easy, was ich machen muss.
Ich vermute mal,
ich muss hier in System-Settings gehen,
dann auf Storage.
Hier, Storage-Device.
Dann sage ich nicht Internal.
Äh.
Warum kann ich nicht auswählen?
Wie, External?
Weil er versucht es ja runterzuladen und das geht nicht.
Ne, VM.
Na, VM ist zum Spielen, doch Mist.
Install on New Disk.
Target-Device.
Yep. Yep.
Alter, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß, man?
Okay, ich glaube, ich muss mal das Wiki lesen.
Warum kann ich das nicht installieren?
Ich habe doch gesagt, hier...
Ah, vielleicht hätte ich das umstellen müssen erstmal.
Any External.
Dass man da nicht die Platte auswählen kann?
Ich meine, wenn ich per SSH drauf bin,
kann ich es von Hand runterladen und drauf-DDen.
Ja, aber das ist auch kein Ding.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich jetzt machen und fertig.
Okay, das mag nicht.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich gucke mal ins Wiki.
User-Data ist zu klein.
Ja, das wissen wir doch.
Also, was haben wir denn?
Patozera...
Äh...
Install User-Data.
Was ist denn die Fehlermeldung?
Patozera install...
Not enough space on User-Data.
I suspect that Patozera is trying to install an update before installing.
He is trying to install an update to my USB.
Okay, was ist denn eine geile Antwort?
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir hier großartig
mit Resize oder so weiterkommen.
Es gibt nicht wirklich was zu Resizen.
Das ist quasi...
Das ist das ISO, was draufdedet ist.
Ich meine, ich kann es auf die Platte dedehen.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch verkehrt geflasht.
Leute, ihr müsst jetzt nicht random irgendwelche Tools...
Ich weiß, wie man Linux installiert.
Ich mache das seit 15 Jahren und verdiene mein Geld damit.
Ich kenne alle Tools, die man dazu braucht.
Also, ihr müsst jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal rauskriegen, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Also...
Theoretisch mache ich das richtig.
Ich muss ihm sagen, welche Storage-Device er verwenden soll.
Storage-Device?
Ach guck mal, normalerweise sollten da die Storage-Devices drinne stehen.
Machen sie aber nicht.
System Reserved?
Sollte da...
Ich reboote das Ding jetzt nochmal schnell.
Sollte da nicht ein bisschen mehr drinstehen?
Ich meine, da sollte doch mehr drinstehen als...
Da steht nichts drin.
Das kann ja sein, dass das Ding keine...
Okay, wie rebootet man?
Da stand vorhin mehr drin.
Ja, glaube ich, glaube ich nämlich auch.
System, sieht einer irgendwie Reboot?
Quit.
Restored System, okay, yes.
Mal gucken.
Wir kommen da wahrscheinlich schon...
Ich meine, wenn gar nichts hilft,
dedee ich das
auf die Platte und fertig.
Denk dran, dass du per Save und Exit
wieder Override machen musst.
Ey, ich habe
den USB-Stick, glaube ich, vorher eingestellt.
Außerdem habe ich die Platte.
Ich habe die Platte überschrieben.
Das heißt, er muss jetzt eigentlich USB booten.
Gibt sonst nix.
Okay, jetzt mal gucken.
Menü.
Network Settings hat er gecheckt.
System Settings.
Was ist denn...
Was hat der denn für Schmerzen?
Kann das sein, dass der Probleme hat,
wenn ich direkt auf das Device...
Muss das irgendwie partitionieren,
sonst mag er nicht?
Kann das sein, dass der Probleme
damit hat, wenn es ein nackiges
Device ist und es nicht partitioniert ist?
Ich habe interne
und externe Devices, also
sollte, es sollte eigentlich,
sollte hier zur Auswahl
paar Partitionen, beziehungsweise
eigentlich sollte das ganze Device zur Auswahl
sein.
Okay, Kingston.
Okay, das wird jetzt wieder nicht
funktionieren.
Ach ja.
Jetzt mag er, oder wie?
Alles klar.
Mal gucken, ob es nach dem Downloaden
noch funktioniert.
Er wollte mich einfach nur eine Viertelstunde
lang tibäden.
Es ist interessant, wie gut Reboot hilft,
oder Leute?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Reboot hilft immer sehr gut,
zwar während der Download.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen Chat aufarbeiten hier.
Ich finde, das UI ist mega nett.
Es ist halt kein
UI zum täglich Desktop benutzen.
Chat, ich habe eine Idee, weil
so viele Solution Zuschauer da sind.
Wir fragen mal
ChatGPT.
ChatGPT
Wird XSolution,
wobei, nee, ich glaube, er heißt einfach nur noch Solution.
Wird XSolution
das Fortnite
Community
Turnier?
Turnie? Turnament?
Oder so?
Moment.
Alter, ich kann ja schreiben.
Gewinnen?
Mal gucken, was ChatGPT dazu sagt.
Wahrscheinlich sagt er, kann ich nicht beantworten.
Sagt einfach gar nichts.
ChatGPT
denkt sich gerade,
doch, ChatGPT kann auch Deutsch.
ChatGPT denkt sich gerade,
was?
Was will der Dude von mir?
ChatGPT kann Deutsch.
Das hat keinen Bock.
Nope.
Das kann ich nicht beantworten.
Wo kann man das einstellen auf der Webseite?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob du es auf der Webseite einstellen kannst,
aber du kannst deine Fragen einfach auf Deutsch stellen
oder du kannst auch
die Frage auf Englisch stellen
und dann sagen,
Answer in German.
Geht beides.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen
hat er jetzt gerade keinen Bock.
Es kann auch sein,
dass es wieder mal...
Ob ein bestimmtes Team oder Spieler
ein bestimmtes Turnier gewinnen wird.
Erfolg im Wettbewerb hängt von vielen Faktoren ab.
Einschließlich der Fähigkeit
und Leistung der Einzelspieler,
Dynamik des Teams und dem Glück.
Es ist unmöglich, die Zukunft vorherzusagen.
Selbst ChatGPT weiß es nicht.
ChatGPT
ist immer sehr
diplomatisch.
Alter, wie lahm ist denn der Download, please?
Hyper slow
Download.
Ist das gerade irgendwie überlastet,
die Seite, alles?
2,5G, keck.
Sag mal,
will du mich beäppeln?
Was, SSH Keygen
minus R
not found? Achso.
Ich muss ja richtig schreiben.
Ja, das ist der, ne?
Funktionen tut er.
Sag mal,
was ist das denn, was macht das denn für Probleme hier?
Nö, gibt keinen.
Gibt keine Probleme.
Auf was basiert denn das Ding?
Hat irgendjemand
einen Plan abt?
Nee, auf was basiert denn Batocera?
Ja?
Arch?
Alter!
Arch, by the way!
Ist es OS-Release?
Es gibt LSB-Release,
sag mal.
Es ist ein Arch-Linux.
Richtiges, richtige, Alter,
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, was ist das hier?
The, the fuck?
Ich reboote jetzt nochmal.
Ich reboote jetzt nochmal
an Stöpsel, das Ding einfach nur an den Gigabit-Port
dran und gut ist. Mal gucken,
ob er wenigstens abkackt, wenn ich,
wenn ich den Port wechsel.
Ich glaube, Btop ist da nicht drauf.
Jetzt
geht hier natürlich gar nichts mehr gerade.
Wifi-Symbol oben rechts,
null.
Okay, wir rebooten nochmal. Also, das ist
gerade keine allzu schöne
Installer-Experience.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich eher vermutet,
ich drücke da auf Install,
das dauert 20 Sekunden,
und es ist installiert.
Dass es irgendwie größere Probleme
macht, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Routing bar to Serralinux. Ja?
Ja?
Sag mal.
Keck, wait.
Wo ist denn das Problem hier?
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Also, es ist sehr
weird, weird champ.
Der USB-Stick ist extrem
heiß, aber, ich meine,
der muss ja nichts machen gerade.
Okay, Leute, ich werde nochmal kurz
mal ausschalten
und mal einschalten.
Hat das Ding Probleme mit meinem Stick
oder was? Ah, jetzt
geht's. Ne, USB-C, USB-C.
Aber der Anschluss
von dem USB-Stick ist ja wurscht. Der hat sogar beides.
Der hat USB-A und USB-C.
Muss ja wirklich laufen die Musik
an und aus machen.
So, jetzt aber. Komm, jetzt einfach
funktionieren, Mann. Ich hab keinen Bock.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich schon längst gucken, ob irgendwelche Games
funktionieren. Also, Menü.
System Settings.
Ich las es
jetzt einfach so, ja?
Install on New Disk. Select.
Dahin.
X64.
Install.
Ja, ist gut. Mach.
Downloade.
Was genau hat das Ding
für Schmerz? Kann mir das irgendjemand
mal schlüssig erklären?
Haben die Probleme mit dem Download gerade
oder was ist da los?
Ist die Seite von dem am Abspacken
oder was? Was geht da ab?
Das ist doch
auf jeden Fall nicht normal.
Okay, okay, warte mal.
Watocera
Download. Wir downloaden uns einfach von Hand.
Oh.
Easy.
Plutscht. Wie sonst?
Was?
Daher?
So, wir müssen jetzt mal irgendwo hingehen.
Ähm.
Mount ist es, ne? So, okay. Mount Dev.
Was haben wir denn hier? SD.
Ja.
NVME, nehmen wir als.
Mount Dev
NVME
0N1 nach MNT.
So. MNT.
Jetzt haben wir Platz. We get.
Bam. Easy.
Wo ist?
Wo ist dein Problem, Mann?
Wo ist das Problem?
Guck mal hier.
Ich mein, gut, der braucht jetzt so busy, aber
okay.
Es funktioniert einfach.
Und wisst ihr, was noch
besser ist? Ich brech, ich brech das jetzt
immer kurz ab. Wisst ihr, was noch einfacher
wäre? SCP
Download.
Image.
Dahin. Slash MNT.
Punkt. So.
Das liegt nicht an Vodafone, es liegt
an dem im Server.
Was das hat nichts mit Vodafone zu tun,
das wird in, in, in
Downloads, Downloads
Geschichte sein.
Ja, wir können mal B-Top gucken, ob er überhaupt
was runterliest.
17.09. outdated für
Arch. Ja, Arch muss
Bleeding Edge sein. Arch muss
eigentlich am 28.01.
quasi schon auf dem Stand vom
29.01. sein. Nur, nur dann
ist richtig.
Barthesera Install
on Disk.
Wir gucken uns mal einen Wiki-Eintrag von denen an.
Install Barthesera on a Hard Drive SSD.
Okay. Video.
Press A on Insta...
Image will be downloaded.
Jajaja.
Genauso machen wir es ja.
Es ist, es ist sehr weird,
weird, dass das...
Will Barthesera nicht in der VM laufen lassen?
Guck mal, easy, gar kein Problem.
Rüber, kopiert, und es funktioniert.
Hier haben wir,
hier haben wir das Image. Ich meine, ich könnte
das Image jetzt einfach auf die Festplatte de-dehnen
und gut ist. Ich meine,
vielleicht war das Image rüber
de-dehnen doch verkehrt?
Da steht, wie das manuell ist. Ich will es nicht
manuell, es soll einfach, es soll einfach mit dem
Install-Menü funktionieren.
Edger, ja super, das haben wir ja gemacht.
Also,
im Prinzip exakt, exakt
das gleiche, wie wir auch gemacht haben.
Flash,
ja, einfach, einfach das
ISO rüber.
Gut ist. Vielmehr, vielmehr verkehrt
machen kann man da ja nicht wirklich.
Das packt, das packt übelst rum.
Du hast
USB-Imager benutzt. Ja und? Ist doch egal.
Unter der Haube
de-deht das alles rüber.
Ich, das ging mir aber doch
erstaunlich schnell. Ich bin, ich
war fast am überlegen, ob ich es nicht nochmal
flashen sollte.
Weil der auch nicht resized hat und sowas.
Komm, bevor wir jetzt
ewig rummachen,
wir flashen den, wir flashen den
nochmal.
Mensch, Logilhype, willst du mich, willst du mich
abfacken oder was?
Eine Fresse, alter, Leute, ey.
Ist ja, was ist das für ne,
was ist das für ein Text, man? Das ist
nicht die gleiche Software, man.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Du bist der, vielleicht bist du jetzt auch der größte
Hardware-Experte.
So. Wir gehen jetzt,
ich, ich flash das jetzt nochmal neu.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das für, und weißt du was?
Wisst ihr was? Wir machen,
ähm,
ne, wir nehmen den gleichen USB-Stick.
Der USB-Stick wird's ja nicht liegen.
Ich hätt gesagt, ich nehm einfach mal nen
alten USB-2-Stick.
Vielleicht macht der weniger, weniger
Probleme. Aber der USB-Stick ging
ja.
So, okay, okay. Weißt du was?
Jetzt, wo ich ihn gebannt habe,
beziehungsweise getimert,
jetzt nehm ich Etcher.
So.
Blum.
Connect.
So. Das haben wir.
Etcher.
Ah, ich hab's ja.
Ich hab's ja dann.
Geil.
Ähm, komm, wir machen das also gut.
Okay.
Flash from file.
Batocera-Image.
Select target.
Das da.
Select.
Flash.
Hat schneller geflasht, oder?
Doch, Twingo, ich glaub da ist irgendwas,
irgendwas ist da schiefgegangen vorhin beim Flashen.
Das war erstaunlich
schnell. Aber dafür läuft
die Oberfläche problemlos.
Ja, also, hat mich auch
gewundert. Unter der Haube
machen die Tools eh alle ein DD.
Wir könnten auch von Hand DD'en.
Also eben hat er schon verdammt schnell geflasht.
Aber gut, das ging wahrscheinlich,
ich hab das ja auch mit 4 MB,
ähm,
das heißt, das ist wahrscheinlich die Hälfte in Cache gegangen.
Na gut, gucken wir mal.
Ich mein,
das ist jetzt ne Flash-Geschwindigkeit,
die lass ich mir irgendwo noch gefallen,
ja. Die sieht, die sieht
realistischer aus als die 15 Sekunden
im Vorfeld. Vorher hat sie wirklich mal
wiii, war fertig geflasht.
Du-du-du-du, du-du-du-du.
Wollen wir, wollen wir
Chat-GPT noch irgendwas fragen?
Ähm,
mir fällt grad nix ein.
Mach danach nochmal mit dem ursprünglichen Tool.
Ich, ich nehm, also wenn
das jetzt nicht geht, vermute ich,
das Ding hat Schmerzen mit dem USB-Stick.
Warum auch immer.
Dann nehm ich nen alten USB-2-Stick
und
dann flashen wir's da drauf.
Aber ich glaub, jetzt geht's.
Ich geh davon aus, dass das jetzt einfach funktioniert.
Würd mich auch nicht jucken, wenn er nicht
zurückkommt.
Also so nervige Leute geben mir echt
Daumenkicks.
Validating.
Nee.
Validaten hier nix.
Gut.
Blum.
Auf geht's.
Ausschalten.
Finished.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ganz sicher, ganz sicher
finished.
Da ist nix, da ist nix finished, alter.
Sag bloß, ich kann
jetzt noch PSSH drauf.
Der USB-Stick ist noch nicht mal,
der USB-Stick ist noch nicht mal drinne.
Ich reboot jetzt, mal gucken, was
passiert, Leute.
Ja, Input-Output-Error.
Okay, ich glaub, ich muss nochmal komplett ausschalten
und nochmal komplett ein.
Okay.
Also, wenn das, wenn das jetzt funktioniert hätte,
dann würd ich mich, dann lach ich mich echt kaputt.
So, ist wieder
eingeschaltet, alles gut.
Aber jetzt bootet er wahrscheinlich einfach gar nicht.
Weil, was soll er booten?
Äh.
Wait a...
Was zum Teufel, das hat jetzt funktioniert
im Hintergrund gerade.
Der hat gerade geflasht.
Die Anzeige ist einfach nur
für den Arsch.
Ich hab den USB-Stick nicht drinne,
Leute.
Okay, das ist ja Fail, Mann.
Das ist ja Hardcore-Fail.
Lol, Alter.
Das ist ja richtig Fail.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Zu viel Doppeltmusik wieder.
So, was haben wir? Super Nintendo.
Classic Kong. Na gut, es ist nix drauf.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal schauen.
Was kann man hier alles so einstellen?
Menü.
Weil du es nicht richtig abwarten kannst.
Naja, ich mein, wenn der Progress hängt
und gar kein Progress mehr kommt,
dann muss man davon ausgehen, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Das ist schlechtes UI-Design.
So, User Interface Mode
voll. Kodi-Settings.
Äh, nein.
Hardware-Video-Output.
HDMI-Audio-Output normal.
Screen-Rotation normal.
Splash-Settings.
Ja, auch gut.
Overclock.
Storage-Device.
Sollte ich da nicht
mehr haben?
Sollte da nicht mehr zur Auswahl
stehen?
Was? Okay, okay. Moment.
Moment.
Wartet mal.
DF-H.
Okay, das hat er erkannt.
Also. Ne, da ist nix drin.
Das ist alles gut.
Äh, Media. Hier.
Dev SDA.
Hier. Der hat beides erkannt.
Slash, Slash Media.
Hat er erkannt.
Ist mein...
Ja, Moment. Hä?
Ah, Moment.
Er hat User Data.
Er hat User Data
auf der SSD.
Und er hat Media.
Das ist mein erster Flash-Vorgang
hier. Das ist mein erster Flash,
den ich nicht abgewartet hab. Kann das sein?
Ja.
Okay.
Und er ist 1645. Okay, das ist der...
Also, der hat die beiden Platten doch erkannt.
Ist doch alles gut.
Slash Media, No Label. No Label.
Ich glaub, ich muss SDA
nochmal neu partitionieren.
Da hat er irgendwelche Schmerzen mit.
Dass er
Probleme mit hat, wenn das
nicht partitioniert ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich mein,
ist okay. Storage Device.
Alles gut. Ja.
Müsste eigentlich alles funktionieren.
Wir können das jetzt löschen, was da drauf ist.
Also, das hier sollte jetzt kein Problem machen.
Media.
No Label.
Das muss ich jetzt theoretisch alles löschen können.
Oder alternativ New Mount.
Media.
Glaub, ist busy. Geht nicht.
Aber ich kann das Film sagen.
Media. No Label.
Und hier drinnen einfach alles löschen.
Weil das ja die nicht aktive
Partition ist.
Hoff ich mal.
Ja, weil guck, das hier ist...
Weil es macht ja keinen Sinn,
dass das doppelt...
Ich hab's ja auch auf der SSD installiert.
Okay.
Ja, der hätte auch gemeckert jetzt.
So, und jetzt haben wir noch
eine leere zweite Platte dran. Ist doch alles gut.
Go. Gut.
Funst.
Jetzt können wir mal ausprobieren, ob wir noch ein paar Spiele...
Oder was man noch so für Einstellungen machen kann.
Storage Device. External. Internal.
Pass mal auf.
Wenn ich jetzt...
Wenn ich jetzt den USB-Stick anstöpsele,
erkennt er das dann,
dass ich ein External Storage Device
angeschlossen hab? Wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil das nicht partitioniert ist.
Du bist wieder da.
Ja.
Das nervt mich jetzt nicht mehr.
Dann halt dich mal ein bisschen zurück.
So.
System. Settings.
Aha.
Okay.
Also, der...
Der mountet alle
interne und den Rest zeigt was auch immer.
Muss mal gucken,
dass ich die Platte
zum Laufen krieg.
Ich komm davon aus,
dass es wahrscheinlich jetzt einfach funktionieren wird.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen wir alles, muss man sagen.
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
Updates. Downloads.
Check for updates.
Start update.
No update available.
Downloads. Content Downloader.
Ah, da kann man jetzt Bilder...
Bilder und irgendwas runterladen.
Also das ist...
Irgendwas anderes.
Scraper.
Ach, da lädt er Titel und sowas runter.
Also quasi irgendwelche Artworks
zu Games.
Network Settings. Hostname.
Ich kopier jetzt mal
ein paar Spiele drauf, wenn ich Windows Share krieg.
Hostname.
Game Collection Settings.
Okay.
Sound Settings.
User Interface. Okay.
Wo macht man...
Stellt man hier... Macht man hier Samba ein und aus?
Hätte jetzt gesagt
Network Settings. Da muss ich mal ins Wiki gucken
bei dem.
Ja, warum das WiFi-Icon?
Samba ist immer an. Okay, das heißt
im Endeffekt... Probieren wir mal aus.
Da ist...
Ah.
1...
Aha!
Ach ja.
Bei ROMs muss wahrscheinlich
der ganze Kram rein.
SNES. Probieren wir mal.
Okay.
Ich glaube, es gibt
für Mobile auch ein paar
Retro-
Emulatoren.
Natürlich nicht in dem Umfang.
ROMs.
SNES.
Ähm. Wo kopiert man dann eigentlich?
Bato,
Serra, Samba, ROMs.
Mach ich das überhaupt ins richtige Verzeichnis?
Store Games on a NAS.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich will es.
Okay, wir probieren mal.
Ich glaube, ich versuche da mal ein Game hinzukopieren.
Also, ich habe hier einen Ordner.
SNES. So.
Kann ich da einfach
einfach die ROMs
reinkopieren?
Mal ausprobieren.
Nehmen wir mal einen.
Super Mario World.
Äh. SNES.
Super Mario
World. Oder
Super Mario Kart.
Alter, wie lahm ist denn der Samba-Share gerade?
Kopieren wir mal rüber.
ROMs.
SNES.
Copy here.
Also, probieren wir mal aus,
ob es funktioniert.
Falscher Controller.
Also.
SNES.
Nö.
Wo muss ich die Games hin kopieren?
Games 1.
Update Library?
Äh. Wo?
In Settings?
Wo habt ihr das gesehen?
Game Settings. Update Game List.
Ah.
Hey.
Wie es einfach funktioniert.
Und sogar, und sogar relativ
relativ
gut zum Original ausschauen.
Poggers.
Okay, Elgato sagt, sie haben ja
keinen Input-Lag.
Bei Instant Capturing.
Naja, so Instant ist es
jetzt auch nicht. Also, ich merke gerade bei so
2D-Platformer Zeug.
Da merkt man schon den Unterschied, ja.
Also, es hat schon ein bisschen Verzögerung.
Boah, ist das. Alter, laggy.
Laggy.
Oh, fuck it.
Das laggt.
Alter.
Das hat keine 4 FPS.
Das läuft exakt flüssig.
50, 60 FPS.
Nice. Okay, das funktioniert.
Wie kommt man ins Menü zurück?
Äh.
Nö.
Welches?
Wie kommt man ins Menü zurück?
Also, der Xbox-Button ist es.
Start und Select.
Ne. Start und...
Ne.
Ah, Start und Xbox-Taste.
Ah, ja.
Okay.
Gut zu wissen. Nice.
So, probieren wir nochmal was anderes aus.
Haben wir noch ein paar Sachen zum testen.
Also, Super Nintendo.
Dass Super Nintendo funktioniert, dachte ich mir.
Ja, das dürfte eigentlich kein Problem sein.
Probieren wir mal.
Probieren wir mal eine Nintendo DS aus.
Also, was? Wie war das jetzt nochmal?
Menü?
Game Settings. Update.
Game List.
Nintendo DS.
Ein Spiel.
System has missing...
Oh, fuck.
Da braucht man irgendwelche
Extra-Dinger für.
Die muss ich auch alles selbst rippen vom Original.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Missing BIOS-Files.
Wie? Moment. Warum funktioniert das trotzdem?
Äh.
Also, anscheinend funktioniert das einfach.
Okay, DS...
DS ist halt ein bisschen doof.
DS ist halt ein bisschen
doof zu spielen.
Okay, jetzt geht kein Button mehr. Alles klar.
Jetzt ist broken.
Jetzt geht kein...
Oh. Jetzt ist RIP.
Ne, moin.
Was auch immer.
Ich glaube so ein bisschen...
So ein bisschen...
Hauptsache die Musik funktioniert.
Aber hier tut sonst kein Knopf.
Ich glaube das ist...
Aber komisch.
Also zumindest die Emulation an sich funktioniert.
Das Intro funktioniert.
Hier funktionieren auch übrigens
alle Tasten im Intro noch.
Ich kann Start machen.
Start drücken.
Aber hier geht einfach nichts mehr.
Ach hier. Moment.
Ich hab da gerade sowas gesehen.
Da ist gerade durchs Bild so ein...
Vom Analogstick.
Guck mal da. Ach du Scheiße, Mann.
Was ist das?
Ich holde meinen Stylus, ja.
Ach du Schei... Okay, das ist...
Das... Also DS kannst du vergessen.
Oh, das ist nicht...
Das ist nicht spielbar.
DS, kannst du klicken?
Aber gut, Touch Controls ist halt auch Müll.
Ich hab sogar noch ein original DS.
Also will ich es lieben.
Lieber da drauf.
Okay, passt.
Nice.
Wir können nochmal...
Also ich hätte noch...
Wir müssen nochmal gucken, wie das Upscaling funktioniert.
Ne, das ist Batocera.
Okay, N64.
Wir probieren nochmal N64.
Und dann probieren wir mal Mario Galaxy.
So.
Hab ich... Ach guck mal.
N64 ist gar nicht drauf.
Oder muss ich die Game Collection
erst...
importieren, dass es erscheint?
All Games.
Eigens...
F-Zero.
Switch, ähm...
Switch Games kann man nicht auslesen.
Okay, das lässt sich spielen.
Nur gucken, wie gut es läuft.
August Graphics.
Ey, das läuft richtig gut.
Ich mein, ich hab lag.
Übelsten Steuerungslag wegen der
Capture-Karte.
Aber es läuft richtig gut.
Ähm...
Wie macht man jetzt Game Settings?
Upscalen.
Game Options.
Advanced Game Options.
Video Mode? Aha.
Hier kann man upscalen.
Guckt mal. Mal gucken, ob das
damit was zu tun hat überhaupt.
Auto?
Boah, was kannst du da noch alles einstellen?
Also, wir können jetzt...
Wir können jetzt quasi sagen...
4K!
Ist klar!
Nee, nee, komm, wir machen mal
1440p.
120 Hertz.
Mehr kann meine Capture-Karte, glaub ich, nicht.
Hier anzeigen.
So, weiter unten war
Texture Upscaling.
Anti-Aliasing-Dings.
Wo ist was mit...
Warum 120 Hertz?
Warum nicht 120 Hertz?
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass das
Spiel intern mit 120 Hertz laufen wird.
Das wird dann komplett
kaputt gehen, aber...
Ah, hier kann man jetzt einstellen,
dass es vielleicht irgendwelche...
bei 16-Bit-Games irgendwelche Filter drüber
macht.
Also, man kann hier...
Texture Upscaling.
Upscale Textures.
Wir machen das mal ohne.
Mal gucken, ob das überhaupt läuft.
Ja.
Also, viel besser
abgescaled sieht das jetzt nicht aus.
Ist das jetzt irgendwie high-res?
Okay, das kann man
wahrscheinlich in dem Game nicht richtig erkennen.
Das ist die eigene Katze.
Alter, wie ich krass... Alter, das ist mega
lag.
Hyperlag.
Okay, keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt besser abgescaled ist,
aber wie auch immer.
Also, N64 funktioniert auch schon mal ganz nice.
Jetzt bin ich
wirklich mal gespannt,
wie das mit Mario
Galaxy aussieht, ob Mario
Galaxy ordentlich funktioniert.
Weee.
Mario Galaxy ist ein bisschen größer.
Gehen wir mal ins
Menü. Man kann... Wir müssen das
dann noch probieren, wie das mit Achievements ist.
Weil man kann ja so... Man kann ja
retroaktiv da jetzt, also
nachträglich kann man irgendwelche Achievements reinpatchen.
Also, reinpatchen
ist jetzt falsch gesagt. Da wird in das Spiel
nichts reingepatcht. Das ist irgendeine online
Bestenliste-Integration.
Ähm, wie das
funktioniert.
So, also Game Collection Settings.
Ne, nicht Game Collection Settings.
Game Settings Update Game List.
Yes.
Weee.
Hat das Lua Support?
Keine Ahnung. Hey, hey!
Es sieht
nach nem Wii-Game aus.
Ich hab natürlich keine, keine...
Die Wii-Fernbedienung hab ich
sogar noch. Okay, wie
krieg ich den Input hin?
Okay. Ich hämmer einfach mal.
Start.
Press A.
Oh.
Ja gut. Wie mach ich das jetzt mit meinem
Controller?
Wie kann ich, wie kann ich da so tun,
als hätt ich ne Wii-Mode?
Du brauchst ja in Mario Galaxy die Wii-Mode nicht.
Du brauchst sie zum Springen und...
Hm.
Wie tu ich so, als hätt ich ne Wii-Mode?
Gar nicht, hä?
Also, gehen tut das bestimmt.
Okay, das muss man bestimmt in den
Game Settings machen.
Hier, Wii. Ne.
Emulate, Emulate
Wii-Mode.
On.
Okay. Gucken wir mal.
Gucken, ob das besser funktioniert.
Aha.
Äh, okay.
Oh, jetzt haben wir...
Oh, guck mal. Ich hab...
Ich kann ne Wii-Mode faken.
Das, das, das funktioniert
erstaunlich gut.
Connect to Players.
Okay, da müssen wir mal
Barthos Serawiki gucken.
Barthos Serawiki Wii.
Aha.
So.
Alter, ist ja klar.
Emulate.
Use your gamepad
like a vertical Wii-Mode in game.
Ja, das ist ja schön und gut, aber...
Er denkt ja, ich hab
bei ner Wii-Mode nix angeschlossen.
Ah ja, hier.
Wii-Mode Sideway.
And...
Nunchuck on Airstick.
Okay, das brauchen wir.
Das hab ich die falschen Settings genommen dafür.
Äh...
Advanced Game Options.
Ja, das da.
Wii-Modes.
Wii-Mode Sideway.
Emulate Wii-Mode Sideways.
Nee, was? Sideways?
Okay, Classic Controller.
Emulate. Swing.
Okay, probier mal.
Das sieht mal so aus.
Aber nicer Soundtrack im Hintergrund haben sie.
Ich glaub, jetzt hat er wieder keine
Verbindung zur Wii-Mode.
Das merk ich schon, weil's so langsam lädt.
Wenn's so langsam lädt, denkt er, ich muss erst mal
ne Wii-Mode noch anschließen.
Jetzt wird er gleich sagen, gibt keine Connection
zur Wii-Mode. Okay, vielleicht muss ich
beides einschalten?
Vielleicht muss ich beides einschalten,
dass das funktioniert?
Ja, wahrscheinlich muss ich's so machen.
Was kann man hier sonst noch einschalten?
Scaling? Rendering Resolution.
Nee, Moment.
Rendering Resolution.
Oh, geil, da kann man, das müssen wir
gleich ausprobieren, da kann man upscalen.
Komm, wir upscalen gleich mal auf 1440p.
Bam.
1440p.
Ist auf jeden Fall nice.
Auf Wii.
Jetzt geht's.
Oh, fuck. A und B?
X und Y.
What the?
Den Controller muss man auf jeden Fall umbelegen.
So kann niemand das Spiel
spielen, Alter.
Mit dem rechten Stick und X?
Das ist ja, das ist ja komplett,
das ist ja komplett unspielbar.
Okay, jetzt kommt Storytime.
Wie, Leute,
falls jemand von euch grad im Wiki ist,
wie kann man
Safestate machen ingame?
Es muss irgendwie Xbox Button oder
Start lange drücken?
Irgendwas
in der Richtung muss es, nee,
was ist das?
Man kann garantiert Safestates machen.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht,
nicht der Xbox Button. Vielleicht der Xbox Button
länger drücken?
Nee. Xbox Button
plus X?
Safestate, ah. Und wie kann man auch,
kann man auch ein Menü aufmachen?
Xbox Button plus A?
Oh.
Ah, das ist Pause.
Xbox, Leute, das ist
höhere Renderauflösung.
Erzählt mir mal nix.
Das ist höhere Renderauflösung.
Das sieht
deutlich, deutlich schärfer aus als
im Original. Guck mal hier.
Das sieht richtig gut aus.
Ich mein, hier fällt dir halt,
guck mal, an dem Gras,
an dem Gras fällt einem halt auf,
dass es halt
nicht wirklich
notwendig war, das höher zu machen,
also höher auflösend, weil
es gibt halt
auf dem Fernsehen bei
was ist das? 720x
576er Auflösung?
Geht halt nicht so viel.
Sieht aus wie auf der Konsole.
Never sieht das aus wie
auf der Konsole.
Im Leben sieht es nicht aus wie auf der Konsole.
Das Overlay
sieht aus wie auf der Konsole.
Die Renderauflösung
ist viel höher.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, die Leute
haben im Kopf deutlich
deutlich zu hoch, wie die
Wii ausgesehen hat.
Das ist sowas von upscaled.
Also es läuft auch
wirklich gut upscaled. Ich mein, wir spielen
das ganze hier gerade in 1440p.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Was war
Safestate? Ah, X.
Also spielen kann ich
es mit den Controllerbelegungen allerdings nicht.
Die Controllerbelegungen
sind
also auf X
zum Beispiel mit Springen und so.
Also das ist
schon auf jeden Fall ein bisschen...
Guck mal, das ist ein Original
Cinematic. Guck mal, wie schlecht das Cinematic
aussieht. Versus das Video
kenne ich. Guck mal, wie
low-res das Cinematic ist. Und das soll schon
besser aussehen wie die Ingame-Grafik.
Das Cinematic ist
halt einfach irgendwie gerendert
halt auf
NTSC und Fahrlauflösung.
Kann man das irgendwie skippen?
Nope. Wird nicht
geskippt.
Ich will gerade noch mal warten, bis man ins Weltall
kommt und wie das aussieht.
Was haben wir noch? XY?
Oh. Ah, Safe.
Okay, jetzt muss ich mir das
nochmal angucken.
Warte mal.
X ist es Safestate.
Und hier ist Safestame reloaded.
Okay.
Und B? Was ist B?
Ah, B ist Restart.
Okay. Aber
Safestate ist natürlich eine
ganz, ganz nice Sache.
Sag mal, hatte
das Game irgendwie nur
zwei verschiedene Inputs?
Äh, acht verschiedene Richtungen?
Okay, geskippt.
Geskippt wird nicht.
So. Kann man? Hm.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Was bin ich sehend?
Die VR-Variante, oder wie?
Screenshot?
Select Slot? Ich drücke gerade einfach mal
alle Tasten. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Selected Slot?
Selected Slot 2? Leute, ich habe
keine Ahnung, was ich da gerade mache, aber
aber Safestate. Safestate
ist schon mal äußerst praktisch.
Ah, ich kann quasi zwei
Safestate Slots
haben, dass ich quasi nicht immer
überschreiben muss, sondern
das ist auch praktisch.
Eiltasten zum Vorspielen. Ich habe keine Tastatur
dran.
Aber das Intro geht ja schnell.
Auf YouTube? Nee, auf YouTube nicht.
Den Stream lade ich nicht auf YouTube hoch.
Du kannst es im Archiv angucken
oder als Watt angucken.
So.
Also man muss ja echt sagen, die Steuerung
ist ziemlich verkorkst.
Ja.
Ins Wasser springen kann man gar nicht.
Wie mache ich eigentlich mein
mein
Spin?
Wie mache ich eigentlich mein Shake?
Gar nicht, ja.
Und der Input ist auch... Also, guck mal.
Die Steuerung mit dem Xbox
Controller, die geht gefühlt
nur in acht
verschiedene Richtungen.
Moment, den, den...
Ich glaube, ich habe diesen
Spin Jump noch gar nicht. Ich glaube, das gibt's
erst, wenn man
den Luma kriegt.
Wenn ich das richtig im Hinterkopf habe.
Ja, Mario Story
Keckel. Wobei ich
sagen musste, ohne Scheiß, Mario Galaxy
war für mich das beste 3D Mario.
Das beste 3D Mario und
das hatte irgendwie eine
halbwegs...
Weißt du, so ein bisschen, bisschen
mehr engaging
Story als die anderen.
Doch, du brauchst
das hier. Das hier.
Mario Galaxy 1. Finde ich persönlich
das beste 3D Mario. Braucht man
für den Spin Jump nicht die Remote?
Ja doch, theoretisch schon. Aber ich hab
das, ich hab das ja gemappt auf meinen Controller.
Ich weiß nur nicht, auf welchen Knopf.
Ich will jetzt noch schnell mal
ein Save State machen, wenn, wenn
die ganze Cutscene Geschichte
vorbei ist. Aber wie flüssig
das läuft, oder?
Also jetzt ist grad
Cutscene, das macht kein... Aber drumherum
gibt's echt nix zu meckern.
Abgescaled auf
1440p
und das läuft flüssig.
Wie viel Watt zieht da? Ich guck mal
kurz.
Äh, 24. 24 Watt.
Auf was für einem Gerät läuft das?
Ein UM690.
Miniforum
UM690.
Massive
Story Twist.
Ja, aktuell ist ja eh nur Cutscene.
Wart mal ab, bis du, bis du Ingame Grafik siehst.
Ich find das sieht richtig gut aus. Also
im Vergleich zu damals auf
der Wii, ja. Also die
Auflösung ist ja so viel höher.
Nein, ein Raspberry Pi 4 schafft das nicht.
Warum heißt das Miniforum?
Weil der Hersteller sich halt gedacht hat,
dass es ein guter Name ist.
Let's Play. Oh ne, jetzt kommt dieses doofe Tutorial.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Jump mit A. Nein, nein.
Ich jumpe nicht mit A. Ich jumpe mit
X.
Und der Xbox Controller ist irgendwie
komisch, komisch
gemappt.
Ja, ist gut.
Intro.
Also ohne Mist, das Spiel sieht richtig
gut aus. Für das, dass es
ein Wii Spiel ist. Upscaled, oder?
Also das sieht...
Also ich muss halt auch sagen, Mario
Mario Galaxy hat so
vom Artstyle und
dieser gesamten Machart
gibt's da halt nix, was ich an der Grafik auszusetzen
hab. Das ist halt ein sehr
sehr rundes
rundes Gesamtbild.
Guck mal, ich drück gerade komplett
nach rechts auf der
Fernbedienung und die ist
echt nice.
Speichern wir mal hier.
Gehen wir mal kurz raus.
Sollen wir mal was ausprobieren?
Wenn man die Auflösung
von Hand umstellt,
ob das irgendeine Auswirkung hat.
Advanced Gaming Options.
Ah, was haben wir denn hier? Dolphin?
Libretro Dolphin.
Okay, gibt's auch hier.
Also Videomode.
Ja, wir nehmen mal das gleiche wie
1440p
120Hz.
Was gibt's denn hier noch? Hats-Up-Display.
Machen wir alles.
Rumble.
Ja, Rumble brauchen wir nicht.
Ja,
16 zu 9 konnte das schon.
Ja, ich muss
auf jeden Fall die Dinger umlegen.
Ubershaders
may not work well on a...
Was?
Okay, was macht Ubershader?
Sieht's da noch geiler aus, oder?
Okay, Hybrid Ubershaders.
16-fach.
Anti-Aliasing.
M.
Okay, volle Pulle.
Ja, das reicht.
Okay, mal gucken, ob das jetzt irgendwie
einen Unterschied macht.
Wir müssen uns das nicht nochmal angucken.
Wir können ja einfach laden wieder.
Xbox-Taste und Y.
Oh, broken.
Wir haben's kaputt gemacht.
Oh, nee.
Oh, jetzt ruckelt's.
Lol.
Okay, Leute.
Es sieht nochmal viel, viel geiler aus.
Aber
es hat so ein paar leichte,
leichte Performance-Probleme.
Kleine, kleine
Performance-Probleme.
Ich hab natürlich jetzt mehrere Sachen umgestellt.
Mehrere Sachen umgestellt.
Ich weiß nicht, woran's gelingen kann.
Wir probieren gleich noch ein paar andere Sachen aus.
Nämlich, also wir machen jetzt erstmal
die...
Auto.
Ich will's auf Auto stellen.
Mal gucken, ob das die Ubershaders sind, die da...
Was auch immer das ist.
Wenn die Musik von der Framerate abhängt...
Ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich auf überall immer...
Also, wenn ich mich darauf verlassen könnte,
dass ich immer auf der gleichen Hardware laufe und so...
Warum nicht? Okay, nee.
Das kannst du knicken. Ey, geht doch eigentlich.
Leute, das sieht...
Das sieht einfach mal so viel besser aus,
als auf der Konsole damals,
Mann. Richtig nice.
Also, da kann man
sich echt nicht beschweren. Das ist wirklich...
Sehr hübsches Game, immer noch.
So, jetzt testen wir mal aus,
wie das
mit...
mit nem Bluetooth-Controller ist.
Weil ich hab ja... Moment, kann
der Xbox... Kann der überhaupt
Bluetooth?
Xbox One Controller.
Kann der Bluetooth?
Die ersten nicht?
F...
Xbox One Controller 2003.
Xbox One Release Controller.
Second Revision.
Ah.
Nope. Game Boy, klar.
Kriegt den... Okay, der...
Der Release-Day-Controller nicht.
Aber wir können...
Einfach mal den PS4-Controller ausprobieren.
After
2006...
Okay, ähm...
Alles klar.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das geht anscheinend nicht.
Ich...
Ich hol mal den... Ich hol mal den
PS4-Controller, ob wir den irgendwie pairen können.
Hat... Hat...
Hatten die ersten PS4-Controller wenigstens
Bluetooth?
PS4-Controller...
Alle?
Okay.
Dann probieren wir das aus. Sekunde, ich hol mal einen.
Boah, ist der staubig.
Ist der...
Der ist staubig. Ähm...
Wo hab ich... Der muss ich jetzt erstmal
aufladen.
Aber machen wir halt am PC, ist ja
kein Problem.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Ich weiß nicht, was da für Musik
läuft, aber muss ja Free-Music
sein, weil sonst werden die da nicht gebundelt.
So,
mal kurz Mikro-USB.
Hier dran. Ich hab nur so ein
komisches Adapterkabel, aber das wird schon tun.
So.
Aufladen.
Jawoll.
Erlädt. Okay.
Äh, wie paart man das Ding
per Bluetooth? Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Wahrscheinlich muss man dann...
Menu...
Game Collection...
Controller und Bluetooth-Settings.
Pair a Bluetooth-Device.
Forget Bluetooth, show controller activity.
Searching for device. Okay. Wie funktioniert das?
Was muss ich jetzt machen?
Pairing.
Ist... Ist das das?
Ne.
Ist das jetzt gepairt?
Okay, jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken, wie man diesen komischen
Controller, den Sony-Controller
in den Pairing-Modus setzt.
Okay.
Pairing failed, jaja.
Ähm...
Pair PS4
Controller Bluetooth.
While pressing and holding the share button,
press and hold the PS button until the light flashes.
Okay.
While pressing and holding the share button,
press, hold... Okay, machen wir.
Share button.
Der Share Button
Pair Controller.
Already running, erzählt doch nix.
Share Button.
Share Button?
Und jetzt muss ich den PS-Controller halten.
Ah!
Pairing Shield?
What?
Nein!
Du sollst nicht das Shield pairen.
Das ist das falsche
Bluetooth-Gerät.
Ja, Pairing failed. Ja klar, Pairing failed.
Ah!
Wireless Controller connected.
Nice.
Okay, das war tatsächlich relativ easy.
Easy.
Jetzt habe ich wireless den
PS4-Controller.
Cool.
Okay, das ging easy.
Eats... Eats... Eats...
Eats Bluetooth.
Äußerst Pogu.
Okay, das war einfach.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz den Sound
ein kleines Tickchen...
Also was? Moin, ich hatte letzte Woche
ein wenig Stress mit einem meiner Lehrer.
Aufgabe war, ein Shell-Skript zu erstellen,
welches User erstellt,
diese das Passwort nach der Anmeldung
ändern müssen. Ich habe
folgende Befehle verwendet.
User Add.
Das wüsste ich aus dem Kopf
gar nicht, ob man das so...
Moment, du brauchst...
Warum musst du
nach einem User Add noch...
Achso, dass die nach der
Anmeldung ändern müssen.
Also Add User und User Add ist ja
eh so ein bisschen unterschiedlich,
je nach OS. Add User ist normalerweise
mit Anlegeskript und User Add
nicht oder umgedreht, kann sich eh keiner merken.
Ansonsten müsste ich
es mir im Detail angucken, also
ob das jetzt...
Also du musst es auf jeden Fall...
Wenn du es
beim ersten... Lass mal überlegen, was
müsstest du überhaupt machen? Wenn du es beim ersten Login
geändert haben willst...
Hm, wahrscheinlich
gibt es da nicht irgendeine fertige Option schon
beim Anlegen,
dass der
nach dem ersten Mal einloggt, dass der dann
irgendwas in die
Profiles schreibt oder so, weiß ich aus dem Kopf auch nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung,
wie man das gescheit macht. Das Problem
ist, ähm,
eigentlich
ist es komplett irrelevant
in der Praxis, also
man stellt
keine Linux-Systeme zur Verfügung,
wo dann
irgendwie 20 User
interaktiv mit eigenen Konten
und so, das hat man vielleicht früher mal gemacht,
aber
die Leute haben alle ihren User,
können dann sudo machen und fertig, also
keine Ahnung,
weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, wie man
stellt, dass der User direkt nach dem ersten Login
sein Passwort ändern muss, aber
das kann man mit Sicherheit extrem
easy googeln. Wir können mal Chat-GPT
fragen, was sie dazu sagen.
Chat-GPT,
wo macht man das denn
noch? Wo
hast du wirklich so einen Remote,
ähm,
Remote Multi-User-System,
Shell-Only vor allem,
wer macht denn
sowas heute noch?
Supercomputer,
ja, okay, man findet immer
irgendwelche Nischenbeispiele, wo man doch
irgendwelche Funktionen braucht, aber wer
macht bitteschön einen Supercomputer?
Da gibt's ein paar Leute, die das machen,
aber es ist nicht
der Alltag. Lass mal
Chat-GPT fragen, wir fragen
Chat-GPT sogar mal auf Deutsch,
ja, ähm,
wie kann man unter
Linux,
wie formuliert
man das überhaupt?
Den User zwingen,
sein Passwort zu ändern
nach dem ersten
Login. Chat-GPT
kann ein bisschen überladen.
Es gibt verschiedene
Untertitel, einen Benutzer dazu zu zwingen, sein Passwort
beim ersten Anmelden zu ändern.
Passwort, Pass-WD-E
zu verwenden, um das Ablaufdatum des Passw... Aha!
Okay, das klingt sinnvoll, einfach auf
abgelaufen setzen und gut ist.
Was?
Shake, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Jetzt, jetzt
Chat, jetzt wissen wir es.
Passwort minus, also Pass-WD-E
Ablauf, äh,
quasi Passwort abgelaufen setzen und dann
beim nächsten Login Passwort ändern. Pfeifert.
Wusste ich auch nicht.
Ich muss in 15 Minuten aufs Klo.
Das wollte ich jetzt noch
machen, also wir haben das jetzt, ähm, Chat,
irgendwas wollte ich doch gerade gucken.
Wie man,
achso,
wie lädt man, wie lädt man denn für die Games
jetzt
eigentlich Artworks und sowas runter?
Game-Collection-Settings. System-Displayed.
Ah, Scraper.
Scrape from
Screen-Scraper. Scraper-Settings.
Ja, das ist gut.
Systems
Included.
Oui. Ja, gut.
Ähm, und wie sage ich
jetzt? Scrape, Scrape now?
Ach, Scrape now.
Da unten ist sogar ein Knopf. Null.
Pff.
Ja. Ach, da muss man sich einloggen.
Errors,
Moment, was für ein Ding.
Errors the login.
Very few less identif-
Ah, ja. Ultrasaurus.
GamesDB.
Scrape now.
Poggers, Poggers.
Geh auf Screenscraper.fr
Ah.
Was haben wir noch zur Auswahl? GamesDB?
H, HFSDB?
Alles
klar.
Du kannst dir noch die Themes angucken.
Ich wollte eigentlich, jetzt weiß ich wieder
was ich gucken wollte.
Ich wollte gucken,
Retroachievements.
Wie das funktionieren hat. Retroachievements.org
Allows you to...
Gamesettings Retroachievements.
Gamesettings.
So hat er jetzt eigentlich...
Moment, lass mal kurz gucken, ob der...
Ne.
Hat er keine Artworks
zugefunden. Ok.
Rango?
Was zum Teufel?
Der ist bisschen
durcheinander gekommen.
Mit den Dateinamen.
Moment.
Gamesettings?
Retroachievements.
Retroachievementsettings.
Ja, DS ist wirklich schwierig.
Retroachievements. Enabled.
Hardcoremode.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Verbosemode. RichPresence.
RichPresence. Ok.
Challengeindicators.
Challengeindicators. Ok.
Unlock Sound.
Anhören.
Xboxachievements. Das brauch ich.
Blim. Blim.
Ach, hier muss man Username und so
eingeben. Ok. Retroachievements.
Muss ich mich mal kurz registern.
Äh.
Register.
Kann man XboxGamerScores sammeln?
Ne, aber sowas ähnliches.
TrafficLights. Jawoll.
Verify. Excellent. Excellent.
FR hieß das Ding, oder?
Screenscraper. FR.
Register.
Ich redger mich gerade mal
testweise mit einer Fake-Email-Adresse.
Ja, inzwischen
abklare. Kopieren.
Username.
Sag E-Mail. Confirm
E-Mail. Passwort. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Registerr.
An E-Mail
has been sent.
Ok.
Screen, Dings, Register.
Wo ist
denn hier der Register-Knopf, Leute?
Register.
Ok.
Using a shared account is prohibited
and will result in your IP
automatically banned. MonkaS.
Ich will kein
Account sharen. Ok.
Register. So.
Omae.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Kann man das vielleicht in gescheiter Sprache irgendwie haben,
dass ich was verstehe?
Hat jetzt das Login funktioniert?
Ach ne, hier registriert man sich.
Envoyer.
Retro-Achievements ist am Start.
Valid. Jawohl.
Welcome.
Ach ne, Moment. Username.
Ok. Yes.
Also mein Username ist
offensichtlicher könnte er nicht sein.
Ich lege mir
einen neuen an, mit einer ordentlichen E-Mail-Adresse dran.
Man kann die Sprache auswählen.
Äh.
Wo? Ach da.
Ok, sogar auf Deutsch.
Ok. In die Zwischenablage
kopieren. Ja, ja.
Forgot your password. Ne, register.
Register. Ach hier ist register.
Sign up.
Username. Jawohl. Beste.
Omae.
I accept. Ich accepte alles.
Ok.
Sehr schön. Also. Dann machen wir
das doch mal. Wir
Username.
Ähm.
Warte. L?
R?
N?
Bester, bester Username überhaupt.
6?
7?
Ne, 8, 6, 7, 1, 4.
Alles klar.
Ok.
Password. Oh ne.
Leute.
Ihr dürft jetzt nicht gucken.
Ich hoffe, dass es
nachher nicht im Klartext
da steht. Ok.
Das Passwort ist zum Glück nicht.
Ok. Game.
Game Settings Update
Game List. Yes.
So. Hat sich jetzt irgendwas getan hier?
Ach guck mal. Jetzt haben wir Achievements.
Jetzt haben wir Achievements
zum Unlocken. Das ist ja cool.
Scrape. Ok.
Ähm.
Das findet das natürlich nicht, weil das
Game so komisch heißt.
Also müssen wir mal nach Mario Galaxy suchen.
Ähm.
Wie ging das andere jetzt noch?
Scrape Settings?
Scrape From?
Screenscraper. Screenscraper Settings.
Wie lockt man sich da ein?
Username.
Ah. Schon wieder.
Aber mein. Es sollte doch hier
Mario Galaxy drin sein.
Man viel.
Wir gehen mal hier. Meta. Metadaten.
Rango. Alter. Was?
Edit des Games Metadata.
Rango. Ja. Genau.
Rango.
Ich habe leider nichts angeschlossen.
Galaxy.
Ok.
Ok. Jetzt sollte er ja was finden.
Oder? Scrape.
Rango.
Alter. Was will der alles mit Rango?
Mann.
Was geht jetzt auf Input?
Ah. Hups. Was jetzt?
Ich dachte ich kann jetzt
das löschen oder so.
Rango.
Ach so. Ok. Ok.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht was ich gemacht habe.
Ich habe nichts kaputt gemacht.
Irgendwas habe ich jetzt gebraked.
Weil ich auf Reset gegangen bin.
Rango.
Vielleicht mache ich erst noch mal Save.
Jetzt gehe ich noch mal auf Scrape.
Ah. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Ok. Rango.
Ok. Hier bin ich nicht eingeloggt.
Aber guck mal hier.
Die haben viel mehr Infos da drüber.
Aber gut. Das ist schon mal nice.
Das ist schon mal cool.
So dass das funktioniert.
Sehr schön.
Moin Patrick.
Das ist richtig cool.
Das gefällt mir.
Ich habe sogar jetzt den Wireless Controller
für die PS4 am Start.
Und das Game sieht einfach mal
so viel besser aus als im Original.
Das ist echt krass. Hätte ich nie gedacht.
Guck mal. Jetzt kann ich sogar.
Das unterstützt sogar zwei Player
mit dem zweiten Controller.
Guck mal.
Jetzt kann ich mit dem zweiten Controller.
Länger spielen.
Mega nice.
Die Multiplayer Optionen in Mario Galaxy
waren extrem unsinnig.
Die Steuerung ist halt ein bisschen pepeger.
Vor allem weil es halt.
Wow.
First Person View.
Mit Input Lag.
Für ein Wii Spiel
sieht das fucking gut aus.
Zumal das ja nicht für
Third Person gedacht ist.
Mit Input Lag ist halt das Spielen etwas.
Ich meine.
Ich spiele jetzt ja auch über die Capture Card
und nicht.
Hey.
Alter guckt euch mal die Grafik an.
Das ist so viel besser als auf der Wii.
Richtig Poggers.
Ne ne ne ne.
Das liegt nicht an der Emulation
der Input Lag.
Das liegt daran, dass ich über die Capture Card spiele.
Ich spiele hier über so einen.
Ich wette, wenn ich das direkt am Monitor habe
ist da nichts mit Input Lag.
Das hat kein Input Lag.
Das ist so krass.
Das klappt auf jeden Fall besser als über die Capture Card.
Über die Capture Card.
Über irgendein Aufnahmeprogramm.
Wie hoch ist die Auslastung?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Gucken wir mal kurz, während das läuft.
Gucken wir mal, während das läuft.
Da wird nichts Input Laggen.
Gar kein Fall.
Ah top.
Ja.
Geht eigentlich.
Hält sich stark in Grenzen.
Die Auslastung.
Ja gut.
16 Kerne ist auch ein bisschen
G-Bait.
Es sind ja eher 8.
Oder was hat denn Ryzen 6900?
Was hat denn der?
18 Kerne.
Ja.
Mit Hyperthreading 16.
Alles klar.
Verstehe.
Moment.
Jetzt weiß ich ja welches Game das ist.
Und wie kriege ich jetzt die Achievements dafür?
Raus?
Oder gibt es dafür gar keine Achievements
für Mario Galaxy?
Das kann natürlich sein.
Gucken wir mal.
Retro Achievements.
Retro Achievement Games.
Ah die meinen Retro wirklich ernst.
Die meinen Retro wirklich so richtig Retro.
Also.
Maximal bis N64 DS.
Die Wii kriegt keine Achievements.
Soll aber bald kommen.
Ok.
All Games.
Vielleicht steht es ja auch unter All Games.
Die Seite sieht.
Die heißt nicht nur Retro.
Hat das vielleicht mal eine ordentliche Suche?
Hier.
Mario Galaxy.
Wenn ich das so richtig schreiben könnte.
Läuft da auch ein Xbox Emulator drauf?
Theoretisch schon ja.
Aber ich habe gerade
kein Xbox Game da.
Für den DS.
Für den DS gab es das nie.
3D Platforming.
Retro Achievements.
Ok. Gibt es nicht.
Also du kannst da drauf
tatsächlich wohl ganz gut auch Xbox emulieren.
Und Xbox 360.
Xbox 360 geht tatsächlich auch.
Aber ich habe keine
Xbox Spiele.
Also ich habe 50 originale Xbox
360 Spiele oder so hier.
Aber keins gerippt.
Das ist ja auch kein Raspberry Pi.
Raspberry Pi würde
auch in Wii Spielen nicht
upscaled auf 1044p laufen.
Es ist so nice.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Ich meine Kodi brauche ich nicht.
Das habe ich auf meinem Shield.
Auf meinem Shield TV laufen.
Gibt es. Chat gibt es noch irgendwas was ich ausprobieren soll?
Themes.
Ok. Das können wir ausprobieren.
Was hat der PC für Specs?
So. Also.
Was der PC
für Specs hat kann ich dir zeigen.
Das ist ein
Miniforum UM690.
Der hat
einen.
Also ich habe die Kombination hier.
Der hat ein Ryzen 6900HX.
Das ist quasi
CPU und GPU in einem.
Und 32 GB RAM.
512G SSD.
Und ich habe noch eine zweite 512G SSD.
Die ich noch hatte eingebaut.
Hier Specs siehst du.
8 Core 16 Threads.
Das ist genau so der richtige.
Wie soll man sagen so der richtige.
Das ist auch der Grund warum ich mir den gekauft habe.
Das ist der richtige Sweet Spot für Emulation.
Du bezahlst irgendwas
zwischen
5 und 800 Euro.
Wenn du schneller haben willst vielleicht ein bisschen mehr.
Je nachdem welche Ausstattung.
Du kannst natürlich auch wenn du dich mit
alten Systemen
zufrieden gibst.
Kannst du was viel viel billigeres kaufen.
Da reicht jeder 50 Euro PC.
50 Euro billig
AliExpress Kiste.
Aber das ist halt eine super Geschichte.
Das ist preislich ok.
Für das was man bekommt.
Und es ist zum ersten mal jetzt
schön kompakt möglich.
Grafik Power und GPU Power
in einem zu haben.
Die Kiste ist.
Ich kann es euch mal schnell zeigen.
Guck mal.
Die Kiste ist im Endeffekt.
Die ist kleiner.
Auf der einen Seite kleiner als ein PS4 Controller.
Und unten oben ein bisschen länger.
Also die Kiste ist wirklich.
Guck mal meine Hand zum Vergleich.
Also die Kiste ist wirklich klein.
So du bekommst.
Eine ordentliche.
Grafikkarte also Mobile Grafikkarte.
Es ist keine richtige Grafikkarte.
Also es ist eine integrierte.
Also es ist keine dedicated.
Auch keine dedicated mobile.
Es ist halt so eine APU.
CPU und GPU in einem.
Die sind aber in dieser Generation zum ersten mal so.
Das man damit ordentlich was spielen kann.
Damit kann man übrigens auch theoretisch PC Gaming betreiben.
Halbwegs.
Also du kannst halt zum Beispiel das neue Doom drauf spielen.
Ganz gut.
In mittleren Details.
Und 1440p mit 60 FPS.
Und das geht ganz gut.
Aber ich habe es überhaupt nicht für PC Gaming.
Für PC.
PS3 geht damit auch.
Aber da musst du dir erstmal ein BIOS runterladen.
Es geht damit alles.
Sofern der Emulator es halt unterstützt.
Gerade Xbox 360 Emulatoren sind ein bisschen.
Naja.
Aber du kannst alles damit.
Also alles was es gibt.
Kannst du damit emulieren.
Du kannst theoretisch auch.
Breath of the Wild spielen.
Aber dann glaube ich maximal.
Du kannst abscalen.
Und dann hast du es bloß auf 1080p.
Was schon mal besser ist als original.
Aber gut.
Es ist eine super Emulationskiste.
Du kriegst 32G DDR4 RAM.
SSD.
Und 2 HDMI Ausgänge.
Was vielleicht ganz praktisch ist.
Für manche.
Und du hast 2,5 Gigabit Ethernet.
Für Netzwerk.
Also wirklich.
Wirklich coole Kiste.
PS3 geht.
PS3 funktioniert sogar upscaled auf der Kiste.
Leute wenn ich eine PS3.
Wenn ich eine PS3.
PS3 ROM hätte.
Beziehungsweise BIOS Files.
Dann würde ich es euch zeigen.
Aber habe ich nicht.
Also wirklich mega. Mega nice.
Pogu.
Extrem.
Extremly Pogu.
Ich bin übrigens 38.
By the way.
Nur für den Fall.
Der Fälle.
Das sich jemand wundert.
Warum ich Extremly Pogu sage.
Ist ja bekannt.
Das 38 Jährige.
Das auf der Welt.
Das ist normal.
Das sagen alle.
Du meinst ich soll hier mal durchswitchen?
Mehr gibt es nicht.
Wo bekommt man neue Themes her?
Muss man mal suchen würde ich sagen.
Wartus Serra Themes.
Gibt es da auch einen Theme Downloader?
Arcade Planet.
Du glaubst bei Downloader.
Du meinst hier Updates und Downloads?
Themes.
Tatsächlich.
Easy.
Was sieht hier ganz cool aus?
Alex Full Install.
Geh aufs Klo.
Warum soll ich aufs Klo gehen?
Interessiert dich das so sehr?
Ob ich aufs Klo gehe oder nicht?
Ich streame seit 4,5 Stunden.
Das ist richtig.
Install.
Artflix Install.
Artbook.
Das sieht so aus.
Ein paar Themes installieren.
Wie viele gibt es da?
Ich schon Busy.
Ich schon.
Das hört ja gar nicht auf.
Habe ich schon runtergeladen.
Was ist das Default.
ES Theme Carbon.
Ist das Default.
Hast du Gigabit?
Alex Full.
Auch nicht schlecht.
die oberfläche ist wirklich wirklich sehr gut gelungen und gemacht so das
haben wir hier controller kontrolle user interfaces alex n g so rum ich finde es
wirklich sehr sehr stylisch sehr stylisch gemacht alles so jetzt gucken wir uns
mal die user interface content oder nee ok das sind irgendwelche 6
leute super textpresa ich dachte ich dachte es ich dachte es
gibt so super touch card einer super talks als beste tout州 art art flix
art of flix
hatten wir noch
ach das ist das was wir gerade ausprobiert haben
schon
das da
Artflix
das fand ich persönlich jetzt wirklich nicht schlecht
aber das muss man glaube ich einfach mal durch
einfach mal durch testen
ich glaube das muss man echt einfach mal
durch testen alles
letztendlich ist das ja nur das Hauptmenü
der Rest ist ja immer das
immer das gleiche
okay das ist für die
Minimalisten unter uns
okay
die bedienen sich ein bisschen bei Kodi
Kodi kannst du übrigens auch starten wenn du willst
also wenn man jetzt auf Fernsehen gucken will
und irgendeine
PVR Kiste hat kann man da auf Fernsehen drauf gucken
will ich aber nicht
weil dann gehe ich einfach auf meine
auf mein Shield TV
und gucke mir das an
also die Oberfläche fühlt sich wirklich gut an
also ich könnte
jetzt zum Beispiel ein
ah gibt kein PVR Client
alles klar
okay
man kann kein Fernsehen gucken hier drauf
weil die
PVR Agents wohl fehlen
alles klar kann man nicht machen
kein PVR
alles klar Leute
Exit Bar to Serra
nicer Stream
richtig coole Software
auch
mega Produkt
dass es so einfach geht mit Controller Pairn
und sowas
Shutdown System
ich werde jetzt natürlich noch mal einen ordentlichen Account machen
ich werde das hier nicht mit dem Fake Account betreiben
es war aber auf jeden Fall nice dass ihr dabei wart
auch ich hoffe dass es auch den übrig gebliebenen Zuschauern vom Solution gefallen hat
ein bisschen was anderes
kein Fortnite Rage
Fortnite Alter da hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Battle Royale ist das so gar nicht meins
aber gut
Leute wir sehen uns
bis denn ich gehe jetzt aufs Klo
und ich gehe was essen
bis denn machts gut
see you